bonjour à toutes et à tous
la commission des affaires économiques
reçoit cet après-midi monsieur Marc
fenault ministre de l'Agriculture et de
la souveraineté alimentaire monsieur le
ministre nous vous avions auditionné une
première fois le 21 septembre 2022 mais
vous le savez les députés de cette
commission sont particulièrement
attentifs aux questions agricoles et ils
ont souhaité pouvoir vous entendre à
nouveau cette demande à notamment été
formulée par Philippe bolo et Charles
Fournier lorsqu'ils nous ont présenté
leur apport sur la grippe aviaire cette
audition s'imposait d'autant plus que
notre commission mène actuellement de
nombreux travaux sur les sujets vous
concernant tout d'abord nous avons mis
en place un groupe de suivi sur la
préparation de la loi d'orientation
agricole composée d'un député de chaque
groupe politique et ayant pour
rapporteur Pascal Lavergne et Aurélie
trouvée ce groupe ainsi que de nombreux
autres collègues participent
régulièrement aux réunions organisées
par votre ministère en vue de la
préparation de cette loi très attendue
pourriez-vous aujourd'hui nous préciser
d'ailleurs le calendrier prévisionnel
d'examen de ce texte et nous faire part
des principales dispositions envisagées
sur les grands axes retenus lors de la
concertation professionnel je vais faire
avril et pour les travaux des trois
groupes de travail mis en place
orientation et formation installation et
transmission et adaptation et
transitions face au changement
climatique sur les questions liées au
changement climatique je vous précise
d'ailleurs que Patrice Perrot et René
Pilato présenteront le 28 juin leur
rapport d'information sur la gestion de
l'eau pour les activités économiques qui
fera une large part évidemment aux
questions agricoles les députés de cette
commission sont aussi fortement
intéressés par les questions diverses
liées aux produits phytosanitaires un
groupe de travail sur la séparation de
la vente et du Conseil dirigé par
Stéphane travers et Dominique potier
nous communiquera ses conclusions le 12
juillet le même jour Stéphane Travert
encore et Hélène Laporte nous ferons
part de leur rapport d'évaluation de la
loi du 14 décembre 2020 relative aux
conditions de la mise sur le marché de
certains produits phytopharmaceutiques
en cas de danger sanitaire pour les
betteraves sucrières nous avons tous que
les dérogations accordées par la France
sur les semences enrobés ont été
invalidés par la justice européenne par
ailleurs l'herbicide S métolaker sera
interdit à la vente à compter du 20 en
octobre 2023 à la suite d'une décision
de landeces dont nous avons reçu le
directeur général le 29 mars la même
agence a néanmoins autorisé
l'utilisation de l'insecticide phosphine
important pour les exportations de
céréales françaises ces questions sont
complexes et le groupe socialiste sur
l'initiative de Dominique potier a
exercé hier son droit de tirage pour
créer une commission d'enquête pour
rechercher les causes de l'incapacité de
la France à atteindre les objectifs des
plans successifs de maîtrise des impacts
des produits phytos sur la santé humaine
et environnementale d'autres sujets
seront certainement évoqués lors de la
présente audition Anne-Laure Blin et
Eric Martineau chargés d'un groupe de
travail sur les contrôles opérés dans
les exploitations suivantes agricoles ne
devraient pas manquer de vos questionner
à ce propos les prix agricoles et ceux
des industries agroalimentaires seront
aussi certainement à l'ordre du jour
bref monsieur le ministre énormément de
sujets et sans plus attendre vous avez
la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
d'abord vous remercier monsieur le
Président de m'avoir invité à m'exprimer
une nouvelle fois devant vous la
dernière fois c'était au mois de
septembre 2022
et un peu plus d'un an après mon arrivée
au ministère et compte tenu d'actualité
à la fois de votre commission et de
l'actualité générale autour du sujet
agricoles c'est important me semble-t-il
en effet de venir devant vous pour dire
les choses qui étaient engagées celle
qui était en cours et puis les sujets
que nous avons devant nous alors je vais
essayer au temps de faire ce feu en
accord avec votre président d'être court
dans ce propos liminaire ce qui n'avait
peut-être pas été le cas la dernière
fois
et j'aurai donc sans doute l'occasion de
répondre et d'être un peu plus long sur
les réponses aux questions que vous me
poserez je n'en doute pas d'abord en
premier lieu sur l'actualité vous dire
que cette année même si les choses se
passent en bonhomme cette année a été
marqué 2022-2023 si je peux dire par la
boutiquement à l'été 2022 du PSN et
l'entrée en vigueur au 1er janvier 2023
de la nouvelle PACS qui est quand même
un élément structurant pour les
agriculteurs de notre pays qui portent
un certain nombre d'avancés importantes
sur la question des éco régimes sur la
question des filières protéines et sur
un certain nombre d'autres questions
cela pose d'emblée le cadre européen
dans lequel nous évoluons et qui est je
crois un élément de stabilité dans le
contexte bouleversement climatique
géopolitique et économique que nous
connaissons mais aussi un facteur
d'accélération des transitions que nous
devons porter la Pâque c'est un élément
évidemment essentiel et structurant ce
cadre européen est aussi celui dans
lequel nous devons ancrer notre action
lorsqu'il s'agit d'évoquer les accords
commerciaux la présidence française du
Conseil de l'Union européenne au premier
semestre avait permis de mettre à
l'agenda cette de la réciprocité des
normes de ce qu'on appelle parfois les
clauses miroirs pour lutter contre la
concurrence déloyale que connaissent
souvent nos producteurs le président de
la République a rappelé au salon de
l'agriculture son opposition au Traité
du Mercosur en l'état c'est une
traduction concrète de cette tombation
même si j'en ai conscience il faut être
modeste le chemin est long et nous avons
besoin de convaincre nos autres
partenaires européens de cette nécessité
nous avons en une année finalisée
enrichie des réformes majeurs je pense à
la réforme de l'assurance récolte qui se
déploie conformément est-ce qu'il y
avait été prévu entrée en vigueur au 1er
janvier dernier à l'initiative aussi
d'une proposition de loi de Frédéric
descrrosa qui a permis de prolonger
l'expérimentation SRP et bien d'autres
mesures visant à conforter le revenu des
agriculteurs et puis c'est
malheureusement le lot des agriculteurs
et l'agriculture nous avons dû faire
face à un certain nombre de crises qui
ont durement frappé nos agriculteurs une
nouvelle fois je pense à l'actuel
recrudescence de l'influence aviaire
mais aussi aux impacts du réchauffement
mathématique que ce soit la sécheresse
ou la grêle pour ne citer que ces
exemples chaque fois l'État a été aux
côtés de nos agriculteurs
pour autant les intensification de ces
phénomènes doit nous interroger ils
interroge d'ailleurs les agriculteurs et
sont aussi des réponses ce sont aussi
des réponses plus structurelles qu'il
nous faut porter c'est pourquoi l'année
qui vient de s'écouler également était
marquée par la volonté de tracer un
chemin clair pour bâtir notre
souveraineté alimentaire dans un
contexte de changement climatique c'est
le sens de la planification souhaité par
la première ministre ce chemin nous la
montre assez sur un certain nombre de
sujets que je considère comme essentiel
et sur lequel j'aurais sans doute là
aussi l'occasion de revenir plus
longuement je pense à la question de
l'eau avec le temps présenté fin mars
par le Président de la République et qui
nous inscrit collectivement dans une
logique de sobriété tout en tenant
compte de la spécificité
des activités agricoles avec une forme
de logique de sobriété à l'hectare c'est
un sujet sur lequel votre commission a
travaillé vous venez de le dire monsieur
le Président
au travers des députés Perrault et
Pilato et aussi la question du soutien
de l'agriculture biologique qui
rencontre une crise grave avec le
renforcement du plan de soutien que j'ai
décidé récemment cela se traduit
concrètement par la mobilisation de près
de 200 millions d'euros et par le fait
d'actionner plusieurs leviers le premier
le premier étant bien sûr le fait que
l'État soit parfaitement exemplaire
d'ici la fin d'année sur le respect des
objectifs que nous étions assignés dans
le cadre de la loi égalim 1 en
restauration collective cela se traduit
également par le plan de souveraineté
sur les fruits et légumes dotés de 200
millions d'euros avec un volet recherche
et un volet équipement je pense tout
aussi naturellement à la question de la
forêt sur laquelle une proposition de
loi particulièrement utile
pour lutter contre les incendies est
entrés en dernière phase de son examen
par le Parlement j'ajoute la
concertation que j'ai initié que j'ai
souhaité que j'ai engagé sur la question
de la haie son développement enfin l'un
des sujets majeurs et sans doute celui
de la méthode et des moyens mis en
oeuvre pour continuer de réduire l'usage
des produits phytosanitaires c'est le
sens du plan Écophyto 2030 annoncé par
la première ministre au salon de
l'agriculture et nous nous commençons la
mise en oeuvre opérationnelle c'est un
objet de planification pour faire en
sorte que nous puissions en lucidité
regarder l'état de l'art si vous
permettez cette expression sur les
molécules les alternatives qui que nous
avons sous la main celles qui font
rechercher pour essayer de nous trou
nous pas nous trouver dans des dans des
logiques de d'interdiction sans solution
deuxième élément structurant et j'en
termine par là c'est votre question
monsieur le Président c'est le pacte et
là le projet loi d'orientation et
d'avenir le président de la République
avait lancé
cette idée devant les jeunes
agriculteurs à terre de gym moi de
septembre dernier nous avons lancé
conformément au calendrier qui était
prévu une grande concertation déclinée à
plusieurs niveaux au niveau national au
niveau régional au sein de
l'enseignement agricole auprès du grand
public et j'ai parié un intérêtment
souhaité que les députés puissent y être
associés c'est concertations ce sont des
relais autour de trois thématiques
orientation et formation installation et
transmission adaptation au changement
climatique et touche désormais à la fin
puisque le rapport m'ont été remis hier
de ces concertations j'attends également
d'ailleurs les rapports qui seront
fournis par le CESU que j'ai saisi de
cette question quant au calendrier il
est conforme à ce que nous avions prévu
imaginé c'est que désormais que nos
capitalisons sur les propositions qui
sont faites territorialement et
nationalement commençons le travail
d'écriture pour avoir un texte qui
puisse être soumis au Parlement à
l'automne prochain c'est un élément
important de calendrier que je voulais
vous dire et donc je crois que ça vous a
été d'ailleurs traduit de transmis pour
ce qui est des contributions et des
travaux qui sont
le donc le cesso doit rendre ses
propositions le 14 juin puis seront
ensuite une fois que tous ces éléments
seront mis en perspective de tracer le
cadre du pacte de la loi c'est un pacte
et c'est une loi une partie relève du
législatif je me défie toujours de
parfois simplement essayer de résoudre
par la loi des questions qui sont plutôt
des questions de système de
réglementation de politique publique qui
ne nécessitent pas forcément de passer
par la loi et votre commission est
d'ailleurs lancé un travail
transpartisan sur le sujet enfin
j'ajoute parce que cela me semble
particulièrement importants dans le
contexte actuel la loi procédant le pack
dont le projet doit procédera permettra
de poser un certain nombre de sujets
dans le débat public nous avons besoin
de trancher et de poser des sujets dans
le débat public la question de l'élevage
et de son avenir doit être posée avec
force pour redonner de la crédibilité
des perspectives aux éleveurs pour dire
que nous en avons besoin à la fois comme
facteur de souveraineté alimentaire mais
aussi pour ce qui est de l'élevage dans
sa dimension de service rendu à
l'environnement et que certains ne
voient pas toujours assez c'est un débat
que nous devons assumer
parce que c'est un élément de
compréhension mutuelle de reconnaissance
de fierté et que ce sont les enjeux
essentiels pour relever les défis qui
s'offrent à notre agriculture voilà
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés un cours
proposiminaire comme je m'y étais engagé
qui permet de retracer très rapidement
ce qui a été engagé cette première année
mais que j'essaierai d'enrichir au fil
de nos échanges sur ces sujets là et
bien d'autres évidemment
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre je
vous propose de passer aux orateurs de
groupe donc vous connaissez le principe
chaque orateur de groupe à 4 minutes
pour vous interroger et vous avez au
minimum une minute pour répondre au sein
de ces quatre minutes donc je coupe un
maximum trois minutes si certains
souhaitent aller jusqu'à 3 minutes je
vous propose de commencer par Nicole le
P pour le groupe Renaissance c'est à
vous
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chère Marc permettez-moi tout
d'abord au nom des députés renaissance
de vous remercier de votre présence
devant notre commission dans le contexte
actuel de changement climatique et de
défi socio-économique il est primordial
d'adapter de nouveaux axes pour conduire
l'agriculture de demain et plusieurs ont
été évoqués dans la concertation de la
future loi agricole je souhaiterais
néanmoins revenir sur le caractère
essentiel d'intégrer les futurs actifs
dans l'univers agricole
le Conseil Général de l'alimentation de
l'agriculture et des espaces ruraux
publiait en avril dernier une
contribution aux travaux préparatoires
opaque et à la loi d'orientation et
d'avenir agricole dans la première
partie de ce rapport sont présentés les
spécificités et la diversité des
nouveaux actifs agricoles avec une
caractéristique commune en reconversion
professionnelle les nouveaux
agriculteurs proviennent d'un milieu
social et professionnels hétérogène
l'intégration dans le milieu agricole
permet aussi différentes formes
je vais dire dès l'orientation scolaire
et pour reprendre les mots du chercheur
Sébastien bis qui était présent l'autre
jour sur ma circonscription il disait
quelque chose qui m'a interpellé je suis
né au siècle dernier j'ai grandi à Lille
je n'ai jamais entendu parler
d'agriculture donc je ne côtoie pas
d'agriculteurs alors que l'agriculture
et l'alimentation par la tout le monde
cela doit nous interpeller et nous
interroger sur l'intégration des métiers
agris et agros dans les ressources du
territoire qui permettrait de
démocratiser le monde agricole dès le
plus jeune âge aussi la formation
professionnelle permet d'acquérir les
compétences nécessaires souvent
spécifiques afin d'exercer ces métiers
enfin l'intégration dans les différents
réseaux locaux professionnels et central
en permettant l'immersion des scolaires
dans les entreprises agricoles
selon le dernier recensement agricole en
France la proportion d'agriculteurs
formés est l'une des plus élevées en
Europe le système français
d'enseignement agricole joue donc un
rôle essentiel en permettant un accès
équitable aux formations et aux
certifications pour tous les types de
candidats d'installation il faut
souligner désormais le travail de
communication volontariste sur les
métiers et sur les formations agricoles
cependant le soutien au dispositif qui
permettent aux populations scolaires de
mieux se connaître et de changer on va
dire les représentations n'est pas assez
conséquent la perméabilité entre les
dispositifs éducatifs doit être
encouragée des passerelles sont
aménagées pour faciliter des parcours
scolaires mixtes des campagnes comme
l'aventure du vivant sont mises en place
mais sans pour autant renverser la
situation alors Monsieur le Ministre
comment permettre de changer la donne en
matière d'éducation agricole en
démocratisant les formations et les
échanges avec les entreprises liées à
l'agriculture dès le collège je vous
remercie merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre en une minute oui monsieur le
Président Madame la député merci
beaucoup c'est l'un des sujets que nous
avons et qui étaient explorés dans les
travaux préparateurs au paquet à la loi
il y a deux sujets en fait dans votre
sujet c'est comment rend les métiers
agricoles plus attractifs
à la fois ce jet d'exploitation et ceux
d'actifs agricoles et donc comment on
fait quelque chose de plus puissant et
de plus opérant sur la découverte des
métiers c'est vrai que l'aventure du
vivant est un outil qui est qui
fonctionne assez bien mais on a besoin
de passer une autre échelle pour faire
en sorte que les jeunes au travers de
leur stage ou d'autres dispositifs
puissent découvrir la diversité la
variété des métiers on est dans ces
métiers là comme dans d'autres mais
peut-être plus en agriculture sur un
contact qui est effectivement contenu de
la démographie moins grand avec
l'agriculture des hommes et donc une
connaissance qui est moins grande des
agricules de l'agriculture et des
agriculteurs donc ça c'est un premier
sujet sur lequel nous vont travailler et
aller plus loin y compris dans les
processus de formation et puis deuxième
élément c'est que nous parlions plus
d'agriculture dans les dans les
différents endroits on pourrait en
parler je pense par exemple à ce qu'on
pourrait faire
aux primaires pour faire découvrir
l'agriculture ce qu'on pourrait faire au
collège et au lycée mais là on est
plutôt pour faire découvrir les métiers
pour faire en sorte que les uns et les
autres puissent mieux découvrir cette
question à l'école donc je reviendrai
tout à l'heure mais c'est un élément
important parce que ça permettra à la
fois de s'assurer qu'on a bien un
renouvellement des générations et deux
on a besoin dans cette société que le
monde agricole
bénéficie d'une plus grande ouverture et
il est prêt à le faire et je pense qu'il
faut qu'on donne les moyens au monde
agricole de pouvoir s'ouvrir merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre la parole
est à Monsieur Grégoire de Fournas pour
le groupe rassemblement national c'est à
vous
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre votre ministère travaille
actuellement à la préparation d'une loi
d'orientation agricole qui sera donc
examinée à l'automne en l'état actuel
des concertations et surtout des axes
que vous avez fixé pour ce projet de loi
nous formulons la crainte qui ne passe à
côté de l'essentiel c'est à dire du
revenu des agriculteurs et donc de la
survie économique de l'agriculture
française alors que nous importons 56%
de la viande ovine consommée en France
22% de la viande bovine 45% du poulet
26% du port 28% des légumes et 71% des
fruits la souveraineté alimentaire
pourtant revendiquer par votre ministère
ne cesse de se dégrader empilant des
normes toujours plus nombreuses et
contraignantes souvent une applicables
des contradictoires la France en arrive
à importer des produits agricoles ne les
respectant pas créant alors un dumping
sanitaire social et environnemental pour
lutter contre ces distorsions de
concurrence il est urgent de procéder à
des contrôles efficaces en effet un
rapport du Sénat nous indique seulement
3 à 7% des produits importés sont
contrôlés pour un taux de
non-conformités qui pourra aller qui
pourra aller jusqu'à 25%. en d'autres
termes 25% des produits agricoles
importés pourrait poser un problème pour
la santé des consommateurs français par
la volonté de mettre en place des
clauses miroir votre prédécesseur a
voulu aller au-delà de la dimension
sanitaire de ces contrôles pour viser
aussi des modes de production cette
mesure pour aller dans le bon sens même
si elles ne vise pas les importations
intra-rennes ce qui reste problématiques
cette initiative c'est confronté à
l'idéologie ultralibérale de la
Commission européenne qui demeure
profondément hostile à ce genre de
mesure puisqu'elle fait l'exact inverse
elle nous impose des traités de
libre-échange qui a accentuent cette
concurrence déloyale et elle impose une
feuille de route violemment décroissante
à notre agriculture je vais évidemment
parler de la stratégie de la ferme à la
fourchette qui au passage a été voté par
les députés européens de renaissance
avec cet échec de la mise en place des
clauses du miroir nous nous demandons ce
que votre gouvernement a fait de la
présidence du Conseil européen qui n'a
finalement eu aucun résultat positif
tous les dispositifs proposés dans la
loi d'orientation agricole seront
rendues inopérants si les grands enjeux
sur le revenu agricole ne trouvent pas
de solutions la question de la
concurrence étrangère des loyale en est
un que comptez-vous faire pour que les
clauses miroirs soient enfin mises en
place
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
allez-y oui merci monsieur le Président
en fait vous poser plusieurs questions
dans les questions vous avez la question
des normes des sur transpositions des
débats des commerces internationales et
la question du revenu sur la question du
revenu je peux pas ne pas dire devant
cette commission d'ailleurs beaucoup sur
ces bancs et surtout les bancs on dit
quand même que nous avons avancé au
travers des galimes des galimes de la
loi des crozailles et que nous avons par
ces lois permis de lutter contre la
spirale avant Chris covid contre la
spirale déflationniste que subissait
l'agriculture depuis des années est-ce
qu'on est assez loin sans doute pas
est-ce qu'il y a pas des filières sur
lesquelles il faut qu'on arrive à aller
plus loin en termes de
contractualisation je pense à la filière
viande bovine sur lequel on a besoin
d'une plus grande contractualisation
pour faire en sorte que ça permet y
compris dans les négociations
commerciales de le faire mais je ne dis
pas que la situation est satisfaisante
mais les textes qu'on a là sur la sous
la main sont des outils qui nous doit
dont on doit encore plus se saisir pour
faire en sorte que la question
alimentaire et la question de la
rémunération soit au rendez-vous ça veut
dire aussi qu'il faut qu'on assume le
fait que parce que c'est un coup ça
imprime et que il faut que nous sort de
la culture
certaines enseignes ou beaucoup
d'enseignes ont mis dans la tête de
chacun d'entre nous qui est de dire le
bon prix c'est le plus le prix le plus
bas et donc il faut qu'on soit aussi
ensemble pour le dire parce qu'on peut
pas avoir un discours sur l'inflation
d'un côté et un discours sur le risque
de déflation de l'autre et donc on a
besoin d'être cohérent de ce point-là
sur la question des normes oui c'est une
des difficultés auxquelles on a fait
face et on a besoin et je l'ai rappelé à
plusieurs occasions de faire en sorte
que nous ne soyons pas en France à créer
de la surtransposition dans des cas où
manifestement il n'y a pas besoin de le
faire parfois ça peut être justifié mais
quand ça vient créer des distorsions de
concurrence c'est impossible
limiter dans le marché commun et dans le
marché unique les distorsions par
l'interdiction des produits
intracommunautaires ça n'existe pas ça
n'est pas possible donc je j'essaie de
ne pas nourrir des espoirs qui
n'existent pas en revanche dès lors
qu'on peut le faire je l'ai activé par
exemple sur les questions de cerise et
qu'on a des distorsions de cette nature
par rapport à un produit phytosanitaire
il faut faire en sorte qu'on puisse le
faire et puis dernier élément c'est
corollaire de pouvoir effectivement
renforcer le contrôle et contrôle sont
organisés d'abord pour les analyses de
risques en particulier santé mais qu'on
ait besoin encore plus au niveau
européen de se doter d'une force de
frappe qui soit plus grande pour
améliorer les contrôles c'est une chose
qui est tout à fait juste merci beaucoup
je vous propose de continuer avec Madame
Aurélie trouver du groupe la France
insoumise c'est à vous merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre nous
député avant hélas l'impression d'être
largement dépossédé de nos missions de
législateur je m'explique la mise en
oeuvre de la politique agricole commune
en France 8 milliards d'euros d'être par
an ne fait l'objet d'aucune décision
aucun débat parlementaire s'agissant du
budget agricole national il a été imposé
par 49,3 cette année et manifestement
les propositions de loi qui ont la
moindre implication budgétaire ne passe
plus les preuves de l'article 40 reste
le projet de loi d'orientation agricole
qui porte sur l'installation notamment
et le revenu le renouvellement pardon
des générations d'agriculteurs
alors je me dis enfin nous allons
pouvoir légisérer sur des sujets
agricoles essentiels et d'ailleurs
toutes les études sur l'installation des
agriculteurs sont formels les principaux
freins pour s'installer ce sont les
difficultés d'accès aux fonciers la
crainte de ne pas avoir de revenus
agricoles stables et rémunérateurs ou la
crainte de ne pas avoir de débouché
suffisant
mais en tant que co rapporteur du groupe
de suivi parlementaires et
transpartisans sur cette loi je veux me
faire l'écho d'inquiétude exprimer par
des députés qu'il compose nous craignons
forts que tous ces sujets ne soient pas
dans le projet de loi après des mois de
consultation j'ai pour ma part
l'impression des agréable que vous
souhaiteriez limiter au maximum le débat
et la délibération entre député car
au-delà de nos différences de position
entre groupes parlementaire je crois que
nous partageons tous ici la même volonté
avoir l'opportunité de débattre de
déterminer dans cette Assemblée
nationale les grandes orientations de
l'agriculture et de l'alimentation pour
notre pays alors je vous poste ces
questions monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous vous engager à ce que les
travaux du groupe de suivi parlementaire
et ses observations soient prises en
compte dans les laboration du projet de
loi et pouvez-vous préciser le périmètre
de ce projet de loi est-ce que ça
inclura ou non la régulation du foncier
celle des revenus la structure et la
protection des filières ou encore le
soutien de la demande en produits
alimentaires locaux alors que nous
sommes en pleine inflation car sans cela
je pense que ce projet de loi passera
complètement à côté des enjeux qui
mobilisent nos agriculteurs et qui
concernent nos concitoyens vous
comprendrez aussi qu'on a été élu nous
députés avec une responsabilité
représentée le peuple orienté le pays
sur les questions qui déterminent son
avenir dans le cas présent il s'agit de
stopper la destruction de l'emploi la
disparition des exploitations agricoles
enrayer l'ultra volatilité des revenus
agricoles permettent aux agriculteurs de
vivre de leur vente et pas des aides
Pâques de réguler les prix et les marges
alors que les profits des grandes
industries agroalimentaires explosent
enfin il s'agit de soutenir
véritablement les agriculteurs dans leur
bifurcation agroécologique tout ce que
vous ne faites pas pour l'instant mais
je suis convaincu qu'il existe des
majorités dans l'Assemblée nationale
pour cela alors comme pour la réforme
des retraites
et ce que fait le gouvernement vous
passerez vous de la démocratie par le
Nanterre parce que vous savez que vous
pourriez être minoritaire sur un certain
nombre de ces sujets il me semble en
tout cas quand qu'aucun républicain
aucune républicaine ne peut l'accepter
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre en
une minute
oui monsieur le Président
Madame la Députée d'abord vous me
trouverez toujours sur le chemin la
démocratie j'ai été député j'ai été
aussi du député y compris une deuxième
fois en 2022 et par ailleurs j'ai été
ministre des Relations avec le
partenaire j'ai un infini respect pour
le Parlement j'ai plein de défauts mais
je ne crois pas avoir celui-là après il
faut que je mette les choses je pense
qu'on peut partager ces choses il y a
des choses qui relèvent de la loi il y a
des choses qui relèvent des politiques
publiques il y a des choses qui relèvent
de la réglementation puis il y a des
choses qui relèvent du d'impact entre la
Société des Agriculteurs vous avez dit
tous les un certain nombre de sujets qui
peuvent être effectivement des freins
d'installation je veux dire il y a un
sujet aussi qui est un frein à
l'installation aujourd'hui c'est l'image
qu'on renvoie certains de l'agriculture
il y a un certain nombre de gens qui
n'ont pas envie de s'installer parce que
qu'est-ce qu'ils entendent sur
l'ensemble un certain nombre de plateaux
de télévision c'est un reproche
permanent et aucune vertu jamais trouvé
l'agriculture encore hier soir
d'ailleurs on va même jusqu'à critiquer
l'agriculture biologique c'est à dire
que où s'arrêtera-t-on dans le
dénègrement donc je veux vous rassurer
nous aurons bien un débat parlementaire
mais un débat qui parfois sera de
l'ordre législatif et un débat qui sera
parfois ordre d'un ordre autre que
législatif merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre je vous propose de continuer
avec Monsieur Julien dive du couple les
républicain c'est à vous merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur ministre je vais
pas vous interroger sur le la ploa
puisqu'on aura l'occasion en long et en
large et en travers d'avoir des cette
question dans les semaines et les mois
qui viennent et d'ailleurs c'est de te
rappeler il y a plusieurs groupes de
suivi et les groupes parlementaires sont
aussi saisis de cette question pour
autant pour parler d'avenir pour parler
d'avenir à notre culture quel que soit
nous agriculteurs qui sont en bio qui
sont en HVE qui sont en conventionnel et
il leur faut garantir des outils dans
ces outils il y a un sujet qui peut
faire certes polémique mais qui est
quand même un sujet important c'est la
question de la place des phytosanitaires
vous avez rappelé dans votre propos
introductif le discours de la première
ministre au salon de l'agriculture et
notamment le plan Écophyto 3 et un plan
visant à réduire de manière assez
importante l'usage des phytosanitaires
avec des moyens mis pour
identifier un certain nombre
d'alternatives qu'elle soit chimiques
non chimiques ou mécaniques peu importe
mais en tout cas d'identifier un certain
nombre d'alternatives mais question sont
donc les suivantes après 4 mois
d'annonce où on est justement ce plan
quelle liste a-t-elle été établie
concernant les molécules qui pourraient
être proscrites s'il y en a une et au
regard des relations des événements
récents qui se sont déroulés avec
l'ancêtre sur le S métola clore sur la
fosse fine pensez-vous qu'il n'y ait pas
justement
l'ouverture à des sur transposition au
contraire des difficultés à travailler
avec l'encens sur l'établissement de
cette liste enfin vous savez que dans
quelques semaines lève ça va remettre
son rapport d'évaluation sur le
glyphosate qui a été prolongée d'un an
supplémentaire au niveau européen par
Bruxelles
ce sera aux États membres de se
prononcer ce sont pas au députés
français ce sont pas au députés des
États membres mais ce sera au ministre
ce sera à la Commission de se prononcer
sur le prolongement ou non de
l'homologation du glyphosate c'est aussi
un sujet qui interpelle nos agriculteurs
quel est déjà la position de la France
Monsieur le Ministre
mais chez le ministre c'est à vous pour
deux minutes merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Député d'Yves vous
avez raison c'est un des enjeux il y a
trois enjeux à mon avis sans être long
il y a les Phyto la question de l'accès
à l'eau et la question de la
décarbonation ou du dérèglement
climatique l'un est en la question de
l'atténuation l'autre et dans la
question de l'adaptation
d'abord vous disiez les débats qui peut
y avoir avec l'anxess il faut qu'on a il
arrive à poser j'en ai été moi-même le
témoin si je peux dire privilégié il
faut qu'on puisse avoir une discussion
pacifique qui ne remette pas en cause en
tout cas ça n'a jamais été mon point de
vue ce que dit l'anxess d'un point de
vue scientifique mais par ailleurs dans
l'émission qui sont celles de lances sur
ce sujet là comme sur la grippe aviaire
comme sur des tas de sujets c'est la
combinaison des facteurs qui peuvent
produire une décision politique et donc
il faut qu'on arrive à poser les choses
tranquillement si je peux si je peux le
dire ainsi deuxième élément on a lancé
un plan c'était au début du mois de mars
on est en train de réunir les filières
les unes après les autres
première liste a été établi une molécule
alors je sens bien je vais vous le dire
la crainte d'un certain nombre de
filières de dire est-ce qu'il y a des
plans cachés non le plan c'est de faire
en sorte qu'on identifie toutes les
molécules qu'on regarde celles qui
peuvent être soumises à ré homologation
dans un délai de trois quatre cinq ans
parce que il faut pas éluder cette
question de regarder s'il y a des
alternatives qui sont possibles y
compris d'assumer le fait que nous ne
disposons pas d'alternatives pour
qu'après on puisse produire des
décisions deuxième élément sur cette
question et donc on est en train de
décliner nous demandons pas en trois
mois de faire ce qu'on a peut-être eu du
mal à faire en cinq ou dix ans mais je
pense que ça participera d'ailleurs de
la mission de la commission d'enquête
qui a voulu le groupe socialiste et donc
on pourra expliciter aussi là où on a
été en difficulté moi je pense que la
difficulté c'est d'avoir trop à la fois
regarder simplement au fil de l'eau les
interdictions et après c'est de poser la
question des solutions on a besoin de
regarder l'ensemble des molécules de
regarder s'il y a des alternatives qui
sont possibles en chimique ou en autre
alternatives je pense au biocontrôle en
particulier pour voir comment on peut
faire me semble-t-il c'est comme dans ce
cadre là qu'on fera bien un dernier mot
pardon Président je ne veux pas ne pas
répondre sur la question du glyphosate
vous savez ce qu'elle avait été la
position de la France moi j'invite à ce
qu'on je connais pas encore la décision
qui va être celle de lève ça mais moi la
question et que je pose depuis le début
et que je maintiens c'est que ces
décisions là elles relèvent du niveau
européen et qui veut donc que ce soit au
niveau européen que nous arrivons à
trouver des compromis
merci Monsieur le mini je vous propose
de passer à Madame Anne-Laure Babeau
pour le groupe démocrate c'était vous
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre merci pour votre présence il
est essentiel que nous puissions
échanger dans les semaines et mois à
venir dans le cadre de la préparation du
texte j'aimerais revenir sur le plan de
soutien à l'agriculture biologique que
vous avez présenté ces dernières
semaines vous avez développé vous avez
débloqué une enveloppe pour le lancement
d'une campagne de communication que nous
pouvons saluer dans le contexte
d'inflation les consommateurs arbitres
au détriment des produits biologiques la
demande est donc à booster et donc cette
campagne à la bienvenue
vous avez débloqué aussi 60 millions
pour les exploitations certains
agriculteurs en bio font marche arrière
reviennent vers le conventionnel ce qui
va à l'encontre de la transition
agricole que nous souhaitons tous ma
question est donc comment allez-vous
ventiler cette enveloppe de 60 millions
d'euros sur 2023 et comment allez-vous
soutenir à plus long terme ces
agriculteurs dans leur métier dans leur
maintien à l'activité
j'aimerais revenir aussi sur le texte
qui a été voté par le Sénat le 23 mai le
texte ferme France notamment sur deux
points
les sénateurs ont voté le report de
trois ans d'un dispositif égalim qui
prévoit 20% de bio et 50% dans les
cantines dans les 50% de produits locaux
dans les cantines
clairement ce vote freine la dynamique
de transition agricole et de projets de
la mise en place de projets alimentaires
territoriaux j'aimerais votre regard sur
ce point et enfin toujours sur ce même
texte ferme France les sénateurs ont
voté la remise en question de la
compétence de lancès vous êtes exprimé
sur le sujet le groupe démocrate
soutient votre position et c'est
l'occasion d'y revenir merci monsieur le
ministre pour vos réponses
merci beaucoup un peu plus de 2 minutes
si vous le souhaitez monsieur le
ministre j'ai un peu plus de 2000 merci
madame la députée je sais que vous êtes
très attentive à ces questions donc
trois sujets le premier c'est
l'enveloppe de 60 millions sur le bio
qui vient s'ajouter aux 10 millions qui
avait été annoncé par la première
ministre alors 60 millions c'est pour
gérer la crise
on est en train de travailler avec la
filière et regarder territorialement le
principe alors qui est en train d'être
tracté mais je vous donne quand même ce
que peuvent être les principes c'est
l'idée de de couvrir au travers de ce
plan les pertes de be significatives
pour un certain nombre d'exploitants
agricoles de le faire sans doute dans
une carte baisse on est en train
d'affiner les chiffres autour de 30 % et
de couvrir une partie de cette baisse de
be dès lors qu'elle serait supérieure à
30% pour faire en sorte que ça puisse
soulager d'une certaine façon les
trésorerie des agriculteurs donc on a
besoin de le ventiler et de l'affiner
c'est ce qu'on est en train de faire
puisque j'ai annoncé ça il y a une
quinzaine de jours de regarder de
regarder dans la concertation ce qui
peut se faire ce que ça peut pas se
faire sans les acteurs puis de regarder
s'il y a des filières qui sont à
privilégier ou pas ça c'est le premier
élément deuxième élément qu'on a à
traiter ça c'est pour l'avenir c'est il
faut qu'on stimule la demande on doit
pouvoir se féliciter quand même pardon
de le dire que nous ayons doublé les
surfaces en bio que nous soyons à 10% de
surface en bio que nous soyons le pays
qui est le plus de surface en bio on
n'est pas aux objectifs qui sont ceux de
la PAC mais il faut quand même se de
2027 puisqu'on a un objectif de 2018
pour cent mais on doit quand même se
féliciter du chemin déjà parcouru ce que
sauf qu'on arrivera à réenclencher la
démarche à éviter que des gens de se
déconvertis au-delà des mesures de crise
que si on soutient la demande et la
meilleure façon de soutenir la demande
c'est que la commande publique soit au
rendez-vous et la meilleure demande une
façon de le faire c'est que l'État déjà
soit à la hauteur des engagements qui
demandent que les autres tiennent et
donc c'est le sens de la mesure ça
correspond à peu près 120 millions
d'euros qui permettra de stimuler la
demande dans la commande publique en
espérant d'ailleurs que c'est un effet
d'entraînement sur les collectivités
locales puis troisième point pardon je
suis un peu long sur le bio mais les
deux autres ça peut aller plus
rapidement sur c'est d'avoir une
stratégie de communication qui évolue
j'ai jamais pensé qu'on gagnait à venir
reposer les modèles dans une stratégie
de communication on a besoin de montrer
l'intérêt du bio de montrer sur quel
segment de marché il est et en quoi il
peut répondre à une demande d'un certain
nombre de consommateurs y compris une
demande locale parce que parfois ça
c'est délié dans la tête des gens de
cette question là enfin deux questions
sur le report de trois ans j'y étais
opposé je l'ai dit au Sénat je demande
juste qu'on essaie d'appliquer à Galim
et Stéphane travers de Me contrariété je
pense la question c'est pas de reporter
parce qu'on n'y arrive pas c'est d'y
arriver d'ailleurs sur cette question du
bio c'est ce que j'essaie de faire et il
faut que tout le monde se mette en
chemin sur cette affaire là parce que
c'est l'intérêt général que de le faire
et l'intérêt de la transformation du
modèle et enfin juste un mot sur lances
pardon je déborde mais comme c'est un
sujet je crois qu'il vous préoccupe un
peu ici chez nous ce petit serait
inquiet je répète la position que j'ai
eu au Sénat et peut-être vous madame
Babou que j'ai au Sénat la question
c'est pas de changer les règles la
question c'est d'arriver à travailler à
la cantise pour qu'on conjointes les
interdictions et les alternatives et par
ailleurs qu'on mette les débats au bon
niveau et qu'en termes de chronologie il
est pas indécent de dire que c'est pas
idiot qu'on ait une chronologie qui soit
conforme entre le niveau national et
niveau européen sinon on crée des
distorsions de concurrence
merci beaucoup nous allons passer au
groupe socialiste alors je crois que
vous voulez faire en tandem ou c'est non
c'est Monsieur petit qui pose la
question c'est ça
mais à la fin quand tu auras toutes les
questions voilà d'accord je comprends
mieux donc l'orateur groupe pour le
groupe socialiste Dominique Pottier pour
non pas 40 minutes pour 4 minutes inclus
la réponse du ministre mais monsieur
petit merci monsieur le Président
écoutez cette audition et l'occasion de
vous dire Monsieur le Ministre que nous
impressions la qualité du dialogue que
nous entretenons avec vous et avec tous
les tous les groupes de ici présents
quel type dialogue quelque part très
clairement à la veille de la publication
des premières préconisations sur le sur
la peine loi que s'il n'y a pas de
foncier cette loi sera un leurre la
politique mère c'est la politique de
régulation du foncier tout le reste j'ai
envie de dire suivra et c'est un peu de
la littérature donc soit il y a du
foncier soit on nous aura pris pour des
imbéciles l'absence de consensus dans la
profession ne peut pas être un argument
le grand edgar pisanique est votre
prédécesseur le grand Edgar Pisani a
fait front au plus libéraux plus
conservateur pour créer les conditions
de la prospérité de l'agriculture nous
sommes sûrs que vous aurez ce même
courage aujourd'hui sur la question des
de la phytopharmacie d'initiative du
groupe parle cancer socialiste s'inscrit
clairement dans une révision du passé un
éclairage du futur en accompagnement
d'une réussite espérée enfin du plan
écofito elle est également une réponse à
une dérive que nous avons encore
constaté dans les expressions récentes
sur ces bancs aujourd'hui d'une dérive
que nous qualifions dit libéral de
remise en cause des autorités
scientifiques et du droit européen donc
elle viendra considérer ce que nous
appelons profondément un modèle français
de l'agroécologie et de la science et de
la démocratie ma question porte sur
l'élevage
nous avons perdu en 10 ans
24% de nos éleveurs
c'est par centaines de milliers que des
vaches tiers des vaches allaitantes
disparaissent du marché français un
quart des éleveurs ont jeté les gants
c'est une très mauvaise nouvelle parce
que sans policulture élevage il n'y a
pas d'agroécologie il n'y a pas de
protection de l'eau de la biodiversité
et la viande que nous ne produisons pas
sera remplacée par l'avant viande moins
10 ans sur le plan social et
environnemental est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire clairement monsieur le
ministre quels sont les évolutions du
plan stratégique
quels sont les évolutions du plan
stratégique national d'un plan de
soutien à la qualité de vie des éleveurs
et un investissement dans les bâtiments
et les outils d'élevage quels sont les
éléments d'arguments écologique tenant
compte du cycle du vie complet non
seulement du carbone mais de l'ensemble
des documents écologiques qui redonnent
de l'espoir à nos éleveurs c'est
extrêmement important le monde de
l'élevage aujourd'hui n'a pas seulement
besoin d'amour il a besoin de preuves
d'amour
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre en
une minute 30
merci beaucoup monsieur potier d'abord
pour vous rassurer j'avais pas dit tout
à l'heure oui le foncier fait partie du
texte enfin je crois que je suis
quelqu'un de sérieux je sais que c'est
un sujet sérieux après ça n'est pas une
loi foncière
il y a d'autres sujets à traiter parce
que vous dites c'est la pierre angulaire
c'est pas tout à fait exact il y a un
certain nombre de jeunes qui ne peuvent
pas s'installer parce qu'ils n'ont pas
les capitaux et c'est pas seulement le
foncier pour pouvoir s'installer parce
que mettre 200 300 400000 euros dans un
système déréglé comme celui que nous
avons déréglé climatiquement des régler
géopolitiquement déréglées
économiquement si on sait pas alléger
cette charge-là c'est pas simplement une
question du foncier la question de bien
poser les principes de souveraineté de
faire écho ce que à ce qu'a dit Julien
dit c'est à dire qu'on est quand même
les moyens de production la question de
l'accès à l'eau est un sujet sérieux et
c'est un élément aussi déterminant que
la question foncière donc pour vous
rassurer il y aura bien la question
foncière je sais que c'est un sujet qui
vous passionne et je suis sûr que nous
aurons des débats passionnés sur la
question deuxième élément je réponds sur
la question de l'élevage
vous parlez d'or monsieur petit on
devrait même faire de la polyphonie
ensemble et j'aimerais qu'on fasse
surtout ces bancs de la polyphonie parce
que c'est pas toujours ce que j'entends
si vous voulez installer des éleveurs il
faut pas dire passer son temps à ne
faire que des crier l'élevage dont on a
besoin
pour maintenir des prairies parce que je
sais pas maintenant des prairies si j'ai
pas d'éleveurs je sais pas maintenant DS
si j'ai pas d'éleveur
je sais pas faire évoluer le cycle de
l'azote y compris pour la pour la
fertilisation de l'agriculture
biologique si j'ai pas d'éleveur et
d'élevage et puis dernier élément et non
des moindres je sais pas répondre à la
question de ceux qui disent il suffit de
faire de la décapitalisation et de la
disparition des élevages et des éleveurs
quand on est même pas capable d'assumer
sa propre souveraineté alimentaire et
donc c'est ça les enjeux qu'on a devant
nous
merci beaucoup je vous propose de passer
à Monsieur Thierry Benoît pour le groupe
horizon merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre parmi vos chevaux
de bataille vous avez engagé un
programme de
réinstauration des haies bocagères et je
salue cette initiative parce qu'elle est
très bien venue notamment pour tout ce
qui est de la question de la polyculture
élevage et de la préservation de la
biodiversité et ça coïncide avec une
directive européenne qui se met en place
cette année 2023 la directive red 2
red2 qui exige des fournisseurs de
biomasse une certification alors comme
demande une certification forestière
celles et ceux dont c'est le métier
un agrément via un organisme
certificateur ça me paraît cohérent par
contre demander à nos éleveurs de des
régions de bocage de Normandie de
Bretagne des Pays de la Loire de
Saône-et-Loire et d'autres d'autres
départements ou de la Nièvre leur
demander
d'entretenir à juste titre et à
l'endroit leur ébaugagère et une
certification red 2 ça me paraît
compliqué ils vont préférer mettre le
bois dans un tas mettre le feu dedans
plutôt que d'appeler un organisme
certificateur parce que ce ne sont pas
des professionnels de la négociation du
bois et on peut imaginer que tout
naturellement un éleveur passionné par
son métier qui entretient ses bocagère
il a par nature envie de valoriser sa
haie bocagère et donc il y a nécessité à
traduire la directive européenne et à
déroger pour les agriculteurs éleveurs
en polyculture élevage à cette directive
européenne ou tout au moins la traduire
de façon à ce qu'elle ne soit pas source
de complexité administrative pour les
éleveurs et
source de surcoût le deuxième point
c'est la lutte contre les nuisibles
parce que on peut être éleveur mais la
poulie culturelle va je veux qu'il y a
de la culture et actuellement nos
agriculteurs quel que soit la région
sont confrontés aux nuisibles qu'ils
soient sanglier qu'il soit corbeau qu'il
soit choucas alors certains on peut les
chasser d'autres sont protégés et il
serait bien que le ministère de
l'Agriculture et bien
prennent en compte ces problématiques et
engage un plan d'action ou un plan
stratégique via le corps préfectoral
afin d'aider nos agriculteurs à lutter
contre les nuisibles et là aussi ne pas
perdre de temps ne pas perdre d'énergie
et ne pas perdre d'argent dans la lutte
contre les nuisibles je vous remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur ministre en une
minute 30 oui merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur Benoît de sujet là et
puis la question des nuisibles sur la
question de Live vous avez raison
malheureusement une contrainte d'agenda
fait que je ne peux pas aller demain
après-midi après le congrès des jeunes
agriculteurs visitait une Cuma qui est
en train de travailler sur la question
de la valorisation de la haie j'ai lancé
l'objectif de la concertation sur l'AS
c'est justement de répondre à un certain
nombre de questions que vous posez en
particulier la question de ne pas avoir
des
comment dirais des injonctions
contradictoires qui seraient il faut
valoriser la haie en fait qu'on veut la
valoriser on peut pas le faire alors
c'est red 2 en partie on est en train
d'y travailler d'ailleurs avec Agnès
mais c'est aussi red 3 c'est à dire la
nouvelle version de cette directive
qu'elle fasse en sorte qu'on puisse
continuer je l'ai dit à un certain
nombre de députés que j'ai déjà
rencontrés de faire en sorte qu'on
puisse continuer à valoriser la parce
que si on peut pas valoriser la haie je
sais pas qui paiera l'entretien et donc
on a besoin de valoriser la haie ça
n'empêche pas qu'on puisse regarder
aussi comment on peut avoir des
certifications qui soient plus allégées
pour pas donner une charge
supplémentaire aux agriculteurs on a
besoin de dans les zones d'élevage
classique dans les bocages on a besoin
de aussi dans les zones de grandes
cultures c'est bon pour l'eau c'est bon
pour la biodiversité c'est bon pour des
tas de sujets c'est bon pour fixer le
carbone et donc pour lutter contre
l'érosion aussi et donc on a plusieurs
sujets moi je souhaite qu'on soit on
arrive à des passionnés sujets il faut
qu'on simplifie des choses pour
s'assurer que l'objectif qu'on doit
avoir que celui de reconstituer le
réseau de en France soit bien atteint et
puis dernier élément sur les questions
de lutte contre les nuisibles
il faut qu'on ait une politique plus
proactif il faut qu'on a un dialogue
avec les fédérations de chasseurs c'est
pas mon périmètre mais je le dis quand
même il faut qu'on en conscience on peut
pas avoir des populations de sanglier
comme elles sont aujourd'hui
actuellement il y a ce que doivent faire
les chasseurs de ce que peuvent faire
les préfets il faut qu'on dise et puis
il y a quelques populations nuisibles
sur lesquelles on a une difficulté alors
qu'ils ne sont pas classés nuisibles
parce qu'ils sont protégés et qui créent
des dégâts et ça faut qu'on arrive à en
parler aussi
merci beaucoup je vous propose de passer
à Madame Marie pochon pour le groupe
écologiste c'est à vous merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Ministre tu as
vu j'ai dit du bien des pesticides cette
phrase qui a tourné la semaine dernière
était sans nul doute un malin de tendu
car oui les pollinisateurs pourraient
avoir disparu d'ici la fin du siècle
avec eux la fin de l'agriculture tout
nous montre que le modèle agricole est
en train de s'effondrer sur lui-même
étant en péril notre souveraineté
alimentaire ce sont bien évidemment les
sécheresses et ses éleveurs qui ont dû
abattre leur boucle l'été dernier faute
de fourrage pour les chevreaux ce sont
ses 60% d'oiseaux des champs qui ont
disparu ces 40 dernières années ce sont
aussi monsieur le ministre c'est de
s'enferme qui ferment chaque semaine ce
sont ces trois quarts de ferme d'élevage
bovins souvent en pâturage qui ont
disparu dans le pays c'est 40 dernières
années au profit de l'intensif ce sont
ces 20% d'agriculteurs qui vivent en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté c'est se
suicide tous les trois jours dans le
monde agricole c'est enfin un Français
sur cinq qui ne mange pas à sa faim des
fils alimentaires qui s'allongent une
inflation qui pénalise le bien manger
pour tous la maladie chronique l'obésité
qui explose voilà pour les constats
voilà pour le bilan des gouvernements
successifs face à ces urgences nous nous
inquiétons du déni ambiant entre la PPL
ferme France adoptée par le Sénat les
déclarations contre la Cour des comptes
ou la propositions
entre autres nous écologistes voulons
vraiment sincèrement un avenir différent
pour nos campagnes aux côtés des
agriculteurs des pratiques
agroécologiques qui se répandent des
agriculteurs reconsidérés vivants
dignement de leurs production le climat
la biodiversité et les milieux préservés
et la fin des accords de libre-échange
climaticides la loi d'orientation
agricole arrive prochainement nous
voulons y croire et nous voulons y faire
des propositions d'avenir si elle nous
réglera pas tout elle peut être
l'occasion d'agir pour protéger nos
terres agricoles mieux partager le
foncier adopter des mesures
volontaristes pour inciter de nouveaux
agriculteurs à s'installer à voir aussi
le courage de ne pas laisser celles et
ceux qui s'installent s'enfermer dans
les pratiques du passé qui n'ont aucun
avenir monsieur le ministre le président
de la République avait indiqué en
septembre dernier qui n'était pas
question
taller dans les modèles d'hier ou
d'aujourd'hui mais bien dans les modèles
de demain nous y souscrivons totalement
pouvez-vous donner des exemples de
modèles emblématiques qui doivent être
laissées de côté car les maintenir
enfermeraient nos agriculteurs dans une
impasse je vous remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre pour
deux minutes
merci monsieur le président madame la
députée
je trouve bien que vous ayez commencé
par vous soucier dans votre propos pas
vous vous souciez la question des
agriculteurs parce que je vous assure
que pour les voir beaucoup comme sans
doute un certain nombre d'entre vous ils
ont quand même le sentiment
que leur activité ce qu'ils font étant
permanence montrer du doigt et donc je
suis contre que dans le dialogue on
essaie de construire on arrive à faire
autre chose que ici dénigrer le bio la
dénigrer l'élevage la dénigrer telle ou
tel parce que je pense que c'est comme
ça qu'on y arrivera parce que je ne
connais pas de transition qu'on puisse
engager je vais dire un mois après
si on commence à dire que les acteurs
qui se vont avoir apporté ces
transitions sont à montrer du doigt et
je vous assure qu'une partie du mal-être
agricole y compris dans ce qu'il a de
l'aboutissement le plus grave il est
souvent généré par des gens qui sont
parfois en impasse économique parfois un
impact de modèles et parfois on impasse
par rapport à ce que les gens disent de
et donc il y a quand même un sujet il
faut qu'on fasse très attention aux mots
qu'on emploie pour ne pas donner le
sentiment permanence de les vilipender
deuxième élément je ne vous donnerai pas
un modèle parce que justement c'est
peut-être là qu'on a un désaccord je
crois pas qu'il y ait des modèles
parfaits l'agriculture de conservation
est un modèle intéressant
il me semble que c'est un l'agroécologie
qui est une autre forme est un modèle le
bio est un modèle intéressant mais je ne
veux pas m'enfermer je ne veux pas
envers mais l'agriculture dans un modèle
parce que je ne connais pas dans le
monde quelque chose qui se construit
dans il y a qu'un modèle passer tout sur
la même toi et c'est comme ça le modèle
c'est quoi c'est un modèle qui soit plus
résigné en face au dérèglement
climatique qui soit plus économe en eau
parce que c'est le chemin donc mais on a
besoin d'eau quand même j'entendais que
certains s'interroger c'est pour savoir
si on a besoin d'eau pour les tomates je
confirme qu'on a besoin d'eau y compris
pour faire pousser les tomates et pas
seulement pour faire pousser du maïs et
donc faut quand même qu'on soit un peu
responsable on a besoin d'un modèle qui
puisse tenir une trajectoire de
réduction des produits phytosanitaires
mais pas au mépris de la réalité et pas
on mépris en disant aux gens vous
retournez à des pratiques dont vos
parents vos grands-parents sont sortis
c'est comme ça qu'on respectera les
agriculteurs et donc c'est ce chemin là
qu'il faut qu'on trouve je vous remercie
je vous propose de passer à Monsieur
Sébastien jumelles pour le groupe GDR
j'ai bien noté que le président chassa
scène devait éventuellement partir comme
on finit dans 8 minutes les questions
orateur ça vous laisse normalement le
temps avant 17h15
la France a perdu 3 millions de vaches
c'est 50 dernières années et 450 000
depuis Emmanuel Macron est arrivé au
responsabilité fin vous êtes pas arrivé
ce matin aux responsabilités et dans ce
contexte les rigueur de la Cour des
comptes ont eux perdu une bonne occasion
de se taire quand il s'attaque
ouvertement à l'élevage français et donc
aux éleveurs en s'abritant derrière le
paravent de l'évaluation des politiques
publiques mais la rue de Chambon qui
n'est pas la rue du jambon et je dis à
cette occasion n'a pas été la seule à
avoir perdu l'occasion de se taire la
première ministre elle-même nous
explique qu'il faut réduire le cheptel
ruminant dans notre pays souvent ces
postures sont très parisiennes très
métropolitaines souvent entonnées par
des gens bienveillés bien élevés qu'on
qu'on pas trop de problèmes de de fin de
mois pour nourrir leurs enfants et la
petite musique qui est en train de
monter contre l'élevage et préoccupant
mais mais ça a été dit par plusieurs
d'entre nous et ça a été dit y compris
par mes écolo nous on veut pas de
déclaration d'amour
moi je vous trouve sympa
à l'écoute respectueux mais on veut des
actes parce que les humiliations elles
sont permanentes pour ceux qui ont qui
travaillent 75 heures par semaine qui
gagne appelle le SMIC qu'on monte du
doigt et compris dans les métropoles
chez moi à Rouen avec la ZFE etc ils
veulent autre chose que déclaration
d'amour ils veulent des preuves d'amour
il faut arrêter les jeux de massacre on
ne convertira pas vous l'avez dit notre
pays sans embarquer des acteurs sont
marqués les salariés contre si on oppose
les salariés contre les paysans contre
les pêcheurs on ne réussira pas la
transition en échouant dans la conquête
de la souveraineté alimentaire vous
l'avez dit et je partage ça mais chez
moi dans le pays le Bray en Normandie
qui a perdu beaucoup de vaches et bien
chaque semaine il y a un atelier laitier
qui ferme et alors on retourne des
terres à l'heure on convertit en grande
culture et alors on importe du lait à
terme
on perd de la souveraineté à terme et
notre pays qui est un pays de cocagne
est devenu importateur massif en viande
on va j'espère s'opposer unanimement au
Traité du Mercosur dans quelques jours
alors ma question elle est simple nous
demandons un plan ambitieux de maintien
de l'élevage à taille humaine des
exploitations familiales un plan pour
encourager les pratiques vertueuses pour
reconquérir notre souveraineté
alimentaire je pourrais vous parler du
bio ouais 60 millions d'euros c'est un
peu mieux que les 10 millions d'euros un
peu annoncés mais enfin ça fait pas la
maille comme on dit chez moi ce n'est
pas à la hauteur des enjeux alors en
quoi votre projet de loi va répondre à
cette impériosité à cette urgence qui
est posée à nos éleveurs et notamment
nos éleveurs laitiers l'occasion
monsieur le ministre de vous inviter à
nouveau à venir dans le Pays de Bray on
y verra des élevages laitiers qui grâce
aux bâtures à l'herbe aux haies ont un
bilan carbone positif c'est aussi
l'occasion
c'est la question de dire en quoi
l'élevage va être utile dans le plan de
décarbonation que nous avons avec eux
c'est-à-dire le maintien des prairies
c'est-à-dire le cycle de l'azote et
c'est comme ça qu'on recrédibilisera le
métier en disant ça de l'avenir et dont
vous pouvez vous engager rémunération et
le rôle dans l'élevage dans la
trajectoire
des carbone que nous essayons de tracer
avec eux pardon j'ai qu'une minute
merci beaucoup je vous propose de
terminer avec Monsieur Paul Molac pour
le groupe idiote merci monsieur le
Président donc moi ce qui dans parmi
toutes les choses que qu'on a pu dire et
il y en a une sur laquelle on n'est pas
revenu mais on va gagner 2 milliards
d'habitants dans le monde d'ici 2100
donc il va falloir une agriculture
mondiale qui soit capable de nourrir
cette population donc j'ai quelques
questions à vous poser alors le premier
bien sûr c'est le soutien à la filière
bio parce que je pense que c'était
urgent et qu'il fallait le faire le
deuxième c'est est-ce qu'on peut mettre
en place un certain nombre d'indicateurs
dans la restauration hors domicile pour
que ça puisse aider justement les les
50% de local et les 20% de bio parce que
je pense que c'est un levier absolument
nécessaire pour nos filières bio la
deuxième chose sur lequel j'aimerais
vous entendre ce soit la question de
l'irrigation je n'oublie pas que
l'irrigation la l'agriculture est née
avec l'irrigation et donc il va falloir
effectivement se poser la question y
compris dans des régions comme la nôtre
ou on dit qu'il pleut tout le temps
quelquefois on aimerait bien qu'ils
peuvent un peu plus et puis la dernière
chose c'est évidemment la question de la
souveraineté avec les clauses miroir
d'une part et je sais par exemple que le
Mercosur bon qu'est-ce qu'on va en faire
si c'est pour concurrencer directement
nos agriculteurs qui essayent en leur
demandant toujours de faire mieux avec
moins et d'importer des produits qui
sont faits dans des conditions qu'on ne
voudrait pas pour chez nous franchement
je trouve c'est pas bon et il me paraît
aussi que le premier ministre australien
voudrait nous vendre de la viande
d'après ce que j'ai compris bon donc je
suis pas nécessaire qu'on ait besoin
d'aller les chercher jusque là
féministe merci beaucoup monsieur Molac
de ces questions
d'abord vous avez je vais commencer par
ce que par le début de votre propos qui
est de dire on a 2 milliards d'habitants
à nourrir et donc quand certains disent
parfois longueur de plateau
on a augmenté la consommation de
l'andouille parce qu'on a augmenté la
population française donc depuis 40 ans
la population française c'est pas tout à
fait la même donc oui on a augmenté et
ce sujet que nous avons en France sauf à
ce que certains nous développent une
autre stratégie démographique
mais la population mondiale augmentant
on a un appel et un besoin de production
au niveau mondial sous des contraintes
qui vont être beaucoup plus fortes
en particulier liée aux dérèglement
climatique qui vont mettre des tensions
et la sécurité alimentaire
c'est pas que la souveraineté n'est pas
que ça mais la sécurité alimentaire elle
est devant nous et le problème sont
devant nous je vous garantis donc on a
besoin de se sécuriser et on a besoin
qu'au niveau européen cette prise de
conscience soit plus grande
femme tout fort qui a été réfléchi au
moment
où il y avait pas la crise en Ukraine la
crise en Ukraine elle est venue révéler
les les difficultés dans lesquelles nous
pourrions trouver les dérèglements
climatiques qui montrent les difficultés
supplémentaires dans lesquelles nous
pouvons nous retrouver donc on a besoin
de travailler sur ces deux sujets ça me
permet de répondre à Monsieur de Fournas
sur la question des causes miroirs c'est
vrai qu'on a posé le sujet sur la table
c'est vrai qu'on est pas au bout du
chemin on a besoin de convaincre les
autres pays européens et la Commission
du fait que nous ayons besoin dans les
accords internationaux de clause miroir
parce qu'on ne peut pas accepter de se
mettre des contraintes aussi fortes que
celles que nous mettons au niveau
européen et il ne faut les mettre qu'au
niveau européen et pas en rajouter en
France si on accepte par ailleurs il y a
des distorsions telles que de toute
façon on perdrait j'ajoute que sur la
souveraineté française l'essentiel de la
compétition il se fait pas avec
l'extérieur des frontières européennes
et se faire à l'intérieur des frontières
européennes vous êtes dans une région où
on fait des fruits et légumes
reconnaissons que la perte de
souveraineté elle est plutôt avec nos
partenaires européens qu'avec des
produits qui viendraient du bout du
monde et donc on a besoin de retrouver
de la compétitivité au niveau français
et donc à pas su rajouter des normes au
niveau français de troisième élément la
question de l'irrigation oui alors une
perm je me permettrai jamais de dire
qu'il pleut tout le temps en Bretagne
jamais
plusieurs fois par jour mais il fait
soleil plusieurs fois par jour donc je
peux pas dire ça mais vous avez raison
il faut qu'on dise en conscience que on
a besoin de la sobriété à l'hectare
parce qu'on va avoir sans doute besoin
dans des régions il y avait pas de
problème d'eau de poser la question
d'eau ça veut dire aussi qu'ils font
qu'on fasse des systèmes plus économo
des assolements qui ou des modifications
de variétés qui permettent d'être plus
économes il me semble que c'est un
élément important enfin sur régalé mais
sur la filière mur oui la commande
publique la restauration erdomicide
c'est bien plus puissant que la grande
distribution en volume et donc on a
besoin de travailler là-dessus merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre on a
terminé avec les orateurs de groupe je
vais donc prendre maintenant les
questions individuelles j'ai à ce stade
20 questions qui sont proposées donc on
va vraiment rester sur une minute s'il
vous plaît essayez de tenir le timing
d'une minute sinon coupera assez
fermement et ensuite vous aurez monsieur
le ministre tout mesure de répondre on
va commencer tout de suite avec Monsieur
André Chassaigne le président Chassaigne
c'est à vous merci Monsieur le Ministre
on a confié au plan stratégiques
nationaux le verdissement de la pacte
des voies diverses et pas seulement des
ONG soulignent un manque d'ambition de
notre PS avec des objectifs
environnementaux climatiques qualifiés
de timide deux exemples tous les
agriculteurs auraient accès au niveau de
base avec un mécanisme d'incitation
insuffisant pour changer de pratique et
passer à un niveau supérieur l'objectif
de 25% de bio en 2030 semble impossible
à atteindre avec un objectif affiché de
seulement 18% en 2027 donc ma question
prévoyez-vous comme c'est possible
chaque année une modification de notre
plan stratégique national une
modification que je qualifierais de
substantielle d'ailleurs c'est
obligatoire qu'elles soient
substantielle pour se faire et aller
vers une plus forte plus-value
environnementale merci beaucoup je vous
propose de continuer avec Monsieur
Stéphane travers Renaissance ce ministre
du groupe
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre le lait vient de faire l'objet
d'un changement de classification le
passant de la catégorie aliment à celui
de boissons les bassins laitiers
considèrent qu'il s'agit là d'une
déclassification le lait étant désormais
placé dans une catégorie dans les
critères sont inadaptés à son profil
nutritionnel le lait est classé au même
titre que l'eau ce qui a pour
conséquence de baisser son niveau de
référence dans le nutri-score ce
changement accidentel point
d'interrogation de l'algorithme est vécu
comme une menace pour la filière
laitière si l'on rajoute à cela la
proposition de la Cour des comptes de
diminuer notre cheptel bovin et ces
attaques en règle contre l'élevage
inquiète énormément nos éleveurs et sur
ce sujet de classification du lait
qu'elle peut être la réponse aujourd'hui
du ministère et votre réponse est le les
travaux que vous allez mener les
discussions qui sont amenées dans
l'avenir pour éventuellement essayer de
inverser les choses merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup je propose de continuer avec
Monsieur André Villiers pour le groupe
horizon merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre je vais reprendre
plusieurs éléments de votre intervention
vous avez rappelé les deux vertus
cardinales de l'élevage la souveraineté
alimentaire et les services rendus à
l'environnement vous avez dit par
ailleurs où s'arrêtera-t-on dans le
dénigrement Sébastien Jumel
pardonnez-moi l'expression m'a coupé
l'herbe sous le pied dans un rapport
récent de la Cour des comptes celle-ci
remet en cause le soutien l'élevage
bovin estimant qu'il y a trop de vaches
et préconise tout simplement de réduire
le cheptel bovin ainsi que la
consommation de viande alors le Morvan
c'est une région naturelle au cœur de la
France c'est 50% d'herbage 50% de forêt
Didier Migaud président de la Cour est
issu d'une commune emblématique du
Morvan c'est la commune de
Château-Chinon où il était le fils du
notaire il a passé son enfance et son
adolescence à Château-Chinon ses études
ont été payées par les activités par les
actes de son père qui consistait à
vendre des bois et surtout des prêts
voilà j'ai pas de question mais je
voulais marquer fortement la manière
dont le président de la Cour des comptes
se comporte avec la région qui
labyronnait
bien nous continuons avec Monsieur
Laurent Alexandre groupe et les filles
monsieur le ministre je veux vous
interroger sur le type d'élevage dans
notre pays à besoins le 22 mai la Cour
des comptes a rendu un rapport qui
appelle à réduire le nombre de vaches et
le V en France depuis 7 ans la France a
perdu un million un million de vaches je
rappelle que l'élevage français c'est
aussi 13 millions d'hectares de prairies
qui stockent du carbone chaque jour dans
mon département l'Aveyron les éleveurs
sont attachés à produire de la viande de
qualité plutôt qu'affoler la profession
agricole il serait préférable de
soutenir clairement l'élevage de qualité
extensif de plein air il faut aussi
diminuer la quantité de viande de gavée
aux OGM et aux antibiaux qui viennent de
l'autre côté du monde et pour laquelle
nous n'avons aucune traçabilité je pense
au sujet du Traité du Mercosur la
production animale industrielle nous
montre plusieurs limites au niveau du
bien-être animal au niveau de la qualité
de la viande produite au niveau
sanitaire avec les risques de pandémie
par exemple la grippe aviaire sur ce
dernier point je veux vous interroger
sur le coup de la vaccination notamment
pour les petits élevages si la
vaccination et la solution proposée par
le gouvernement elle ne doit pas être à
la charge des éleveurs mais de la
solidarité nationale merci pour le
groupe pour les démocrates monsieur
boulot
merci Monsieur le merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre je
voudrais revenir un peu sur la ligne
fiançailles au terme du rapport que nous
avons mené avec mon collègue Charles
Fournier saluer le travail et les
efforts importants consentis par le
ministère et service des concentrés pour
faire face à une situation
exceptionnelle je voudrais aussi saluer
l'effort financiers de 1 milliard
d'euros qui a été déployé pour l'État
sur cet effort financier nous remonte
actuellement des difficultés de
versement des aides il faut reconnaître
la complexité de ces indemnisations avec
des successions de vagues de virus des
territoires toucher les uns après les
autres et des éleveurs qui ont pu vivre
plusieurs crises conscient de ces
difficultés je voudrais vous alerter sur
un sujet plus particulier celui des
éleveurs qui ont contractualisé avec des
entreprises sans avoir en retour les
aides perçues par ces entreprises je
fais notamment référence aux akuvres
monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous nous
dire si ces entreprises ont été payées
et sans vous demander de faire preuve
d'ingérence dans ces entreprises dans
ces sociétés comment l'État peut-il
faire pour peser sur ces entreprises
afin que les versements qu'elles ont
perçu retombent bien le plus rapidement
possible vers les éleveurs merci
beaucoup monsieur vin cent Roland groupe
LR
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je me fais le porte-parole des
agriculteurs de mon territoire et de
tous ceux qui sont touchés par les
dégâts de la prédation il vous demande
de les entendre et d'agir concrètement
pour réguler un véritable fléau qui est
le loup et qui est toujours plus
nombreux dans nos territoires il faut
régler ce problème avant qu'il ne décime
les exploitations agricoles il y a aussi
un autre problème celui de la
transmission de la bruxellose par les
bouquetins qui là aussi fait peser un
risque majeur sur une agriculture
d'ailleurs que l'on appelle vertueuse
puisque la plupart du temps elle est
sous signe d'AOP ou d'IGP et qu'elle se
fait de manière tout à fait extensive il
me semblait que c'était un modèle que
l'État devait mettre en avant et surtout
défendre de manière énergique puisque
aujourd'hui la situation n'est plus du
tout tenable
merci beaucoup Marie-Noëlle Battistel
pour le groupe socialiste merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre je
voulais vous interroger j'ai deux
questions concernant la PAC les
agriculteurs sortent de leur déclaration
et il constate en tout cas sur mon
territoire une défaillance de l'outil
téléclaration notamment les calculettes
de l'outil qui du coup leur permet pas
d'avoir la visibilité s'ils sont
éligibles ou non à certains dispositifs
donc c'est quand même un vrai problème
donc je ne sais pas si c'est remonter
jusqu'à vous mais en tout cas je vous le
dis et puis la deuxième question sur la
PAC c'est la question de la prise en
compte de l'inflation que nous
connaissons actuellement et le mode de
fonctionnement actuel de l'Europe n'a
pas permis d'être suffisamment réactif
dans le cas de de crise comme celle que
nous traversons selon certains calculs
cette année le budget de la pacte pour
la France a perdu 5 milliards d'euros
constants si on avait appliqué le taux
d'inflation on aurait eu cela en plus et
puis peut-être un dernier mot sur le
service de remplacement des bergers d'Al
age est-ce que vous avez travaillé sur
ce sujet pour qu'il puisse être intégré
dans le coude à la prédation merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup monsieur
Aurélien lopezzigori pour le groupe
rassemblement national
monsieur le ministre merci monsieur le
Président lourdeur administrative baisse
de la consommation de vin changement
climatique multiplication des contrôles
qui vont de pair avec une
surréglementation croissante les
viticulteurs seront abandonnés délaissés
et les cris s'accumulent comme si cela
ne suffisait pas sentez publique France
a lancé en janvier sa campagne pour un
mois sans alcool sur les communications
gouvernementales plusieurs scènes dont
une avec des Français autour d'une table
trinquant avec leur verre de vin et le
message transmis est simple et il est
terrible pour nos viticulteurs un verre
de vin consommé c'est déjà un verre de
trop les professionnels en fait part de
leur sidération à la vue de ses
campagnes il ne comprennent pas et nous
ne comprenons pas non plus pourquoi on
les fustige alors qu'ils sont en pleine
crise alors monsieur le ministre que
faites-vous pour protéger le monde du
vin de ses campagnes de communication
destructrice et pouvez-vous nous
garantir que ce genre de communication
sera la dernière merci merci Monsieur
Giovanni Williams pour le groupe GDR
mes collègues sénateurs
merci Monsieur merci mon cher collègue
ce sera la prochaine la prochaine merci
beaucoup la parité annonce pétale pour
le groupe Renaissance
bonjour monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président merci beaucoup
en prenant ça un peu Côte d'Azur en 2022
du 1er janvier au 10 avril il est tombé
64 mm de pluie un record depuis 1959 en
2023 l'année a commencé de la même
manière et il est récente pluie sont une
bonne nouvelle mais en raison de
l'évaporation et de l'absorption par les
plantes et bien la sécheresse va très
certainement perdurer les agriculteurs
eux font face à un défi incroyable et à
plusieurs enjeux celui de garantir la
souveraineté alimentaire de la France
d'assurer la transition générationnelle
de leurs exploitations s'adapter aux 100
changements climatique vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure il nous faut une
agriculture plus résiliente plus économe
de la ressource en eau c'est sur ce
point que je souhaite vous interroger et
savoir sur justement l'utilisation de la
ressource en eau et la sobriété ce que
vous pensez de l'agrivoltaïsme que nous
avons encadré dans le dans la loi sur
les EnR et je souhaiterais connaître
votre point de vue sur l'usage des
ombrières photovoltaïques dynamique et
également de l'irrigation connectée
merci
monsieur le ministre comme vous le savez
car nous avons échangé ensemble sur le
sujet la tuberculose bovine est en train
de gagner du terrain en Normandie cette
situation inquiète nos éleveurs
notamment dans l'Orne ce qui se trouve
au coeur de la oprue et qui voit la zone
de profilaxie renforcée s'étendre
fortement suite à plusieurs cas positifs
c'est donc toute la filière élevage lait
qui est en danger non seulement nous
avons besoin que l'état indemniste de
manière juste les exploitations
concernées et accompagnent pleinement
nos éleveurs en détresse totale quand
leur troupeau est abattu mais nous avons
aussi besoin de renforcer la protection
des élevages en régulant plus vite et de
manière plus volontariste le blaireau
porteur de la tuberculose et aussi en
permettant des financements croisés
conseil départemental et conseils
régional pour arriver à 80% d'aide pour
mettre en oeuvre des mesures de
biosécurité dans les exploitations
touchées monsieur le ministre il y a
urgence nous avons besoin de votre aide
concrète sur ce sujet merci beaucoup
Monsieur Eric Martineau pour le groupe
démocrate
susceptible de contenir des résidus de
mes produits phytaux interdits en France
je vous remercie merci beaucoup Madame
Florence Goulet pour l'ORL
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre la loi egalim du 30 octobre
2018 était censé promouvoir
l'agriculture et développer la
consommation locale selon son article 24
modifié depuis au plus tard le 1er
janvier 2023 les repas servis dans les
restaurants collectifs devaient servir
au moins 80% de produits correspondants
aux exigences des courts-circuits courts
et 50% aux exigences du bio pourtant les
acheteurs publics n'ont pas le droit
d'introduire des critères de proximité
dans leurs appels d'offres pour
contourner cette interdiction
incompréhensible alors que les acteurs
économiques privés en ont la possibilité
les collectivités sont contraintes de
redoubler d'ingéniosité juridique pour
contourner cette interdiction au risque
de contentieux et de complexification
des marchés publics déjà peu accessibles
aux petits producteurs une récente
tribune appelée à créer une exception
alimentaire et agricole à l'image du
modèle de l'exception culturelle quel
est votre avis sur cette proposition
d'exception agriculturelle que nous que
le groupe rassemblement national défend
et prévoyez-vous une action en ce sens
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup d'avoir
été iniyaki et Janis groupe socialiste
merci monsieur le ministre je souhaite
de nouveau attirer votre attention après
les courriers que vous avez reçu sur
l'épisode de sécheresse qu'on connait
les Pyrénées-Atlantiques durant l'année
2022 et ses conséquences inédites sur
l'activité agricole de notre territoire
vous connaissez bien la spécificité de
l'agriculture dans les
Pyrénées-Atlantiques des exploitations
de petite taille et l'activité de
montagne avec l'utilisation massive et
importante des estives si le dispositif
d'être déployé par l'État a permis
l'indemnisation d'une part importante
des professionnels les plus durement
touchées en 2022 de nombreux exploitants
restent malheureusement excuses pour des
raisons de seuil d'éligibilité ou de non
traitement de leurs dossier pourtant
aucun agriculteur et éleveur n'a échappé
à la calamité sécheresse durant l'année
écoulée cette situation est mal vécue
localement puisqu'elle nourrit un
sentiment légitime d'iniquité accentuée
par le pôle lisibilité du système de
calcul des aides certaines incohérences
renforcent cette incompréhension comme
l'intégration des aides attribuées aux
jeunes agriculteurs dans le calcul de
leurs produits brut théorique ou les
critères de race ou de pratique
notamment la question de l'estive face à
l'urgence il appartient à l'État de
prendre en charge cette tondeuse pour
tous les agriculteurs touchés notamment
en
utilisant le reliquat des centres
clichés quelle est votre avis merci
beaucoup Monsieur Patrice Perrault Paul
Renaissance oui merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre je vais
revenir sur le récent rapport de la Cour
des comptes concernant la réduction du
cheptel bovin et de la consommation de
viande en France c'était nombreuses
crispations notamment au travers les
collègues et bien évidemment la
profession est au cœur du territoire
Nivernais que j'ai l'honneur de
représenter
la Cour des comptes souligne une
prétendue une équation entre les aides
octroyées à l'élevage bovins et le
bénéfice qui résiste ainsi que les
impacts environnementaux du secteur nous
parlons surtout de nos pâturages de
notre économie locale
et notre souveraineté alimentaire ces
questions méritent plus qu'une analyse
comptable qui fait surtout fait d'une
concurrence mondialisée globalisée qui
se moque bien de ce genre d'atermoiement
franco-français c'est pourquoi Monsieur
le Ministre bien conscient des enjeux
globaux et notamment environnementaux
comment comptez-vous concilier nos
nécessité de réduire les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre du secteur agricole
garantir la pérennité des exploitations
et le renouvellement des générations et
d'assurer la souveraineté alimentaire de
notre pays merci beaucoup madame Marie
bochon pour le groupe écologiste
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre j'y gagne à ce que mes
annielles se fassent bouffer par le loup
je remporte 200 euros par année
l'attaqué elle valent pas de 100 euros
mais ce sont mes Agnels c'est la parole
d'un éleveur de moi qui lors du week-end
de Pâques s'est fait attaquer par deux
fois malgré 5 chiens à parc électrique à
20 mètres des habitations à
Beaumont-lès-Valence dans la plaine
bromoise en 2022 mon département a vu se
dérouler 167 attaques derrière ses
attaques ce sont des éleveurs qui dure
au lendemain perdent tout
l'indemnisation des bêtes perdus ne
suffit pas à les consoler l'activité
pastorale est essentielle à bien des
égards à nos territoires de montagne le
loup espèce protégée par la Convention
de Berne y est aussi chez lui j'insiste
malgré les expérimentations les demandes
d'investir dans la recherche et je pense
là à celle nommée menée par le PNR du
Vercors les tensions montent dans mon
département instrumentalisée par
certains loin du dialogue les défis sont
immenses concurrence déloyale de la
mondialisation raréfaction et
renchérissement des prix du foncier
calcule des subventions pack
défavorables aux petites exploitations
multiplication des sécheresses liées au
changement climatiques la prédation qui
sévit dans la Drôme sans creux dans un
contexte déjà intenable pour le
pastoralisme monsieur le ministre
comment comptez-vous permettre le retour
du dialogue dans nos montagnes et
comptez-vous publier en ce sens le bilan
du premier plan Louis je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame Louise Morel pour
le groupe démocrate merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre le
dernier aussi une question sur le
dernier rapport de la Cour des comptes
qui nous a l'air sur les conséquences
climatiques et environnementales de
notre agriculture et plus
particulièrement sur les émissions de
méthane qui sont issues de l'élevage
bovin dans ce rapport est préconisé la
diminution du cheptel bovin et de la
consommation de viande en parallèle
l'Institut de l'économie nous dit que la
consommation de viande n'a cessé
d'augmenter depuis les dernières 50
années alors comment diminuer nos
émissions la France a signé avec la
cop26 le Global Messan pledge et les
réponses apportées sont très variées
ajoutent d'additifs alimentaires
modification génétique sur les animaux
d'autres prônent des solutions plus
naturelles telles que le retour aux
pâturages de prairies naturelles donc ma
question elle est simple quel est votre
position face à cette diversité de
solutions quelles sont vos solutions
pour répondre à la diminution de nos
émissions de méthane et pour répondre à
cette problématique je vous remercie
merci beaucoup Monsieur Jean-Pierre
Vigier pour le groupe à merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Ministre
honteux scandaleuse inadmissible voire
méprisante avec le monde de l'élevage
français tels sont les conclusions du
rapport de la Cour des comptes et je
cite une stratégie de réduction du
cheptel bovin l'élevage français est
l'un des plus reconnus au monde il
contribue à l'emploi à l'ouverture des
paysages à la gestion de la biodiversité
et surtout à nourrir notre population
avec des produits de grande qualité il
s'agit d'une activité vitale pour nos
territoires notre mandarricole ce sont
les écologistes de France en réduisant
le cheptel c'est la production française
qui sera impactée et les importations de
viande de moindres qualités favorisées
nous devons bien au contraire faire de
l'élevage un atout majeur pour notre
souveraineté alimentaire notamment en
luttant contre l'agribashing et en
relevant le défi du renouvellement des
générations alors Monsieur le Ministre
comment comptez-vous concrètement
soutenir notre élevage français je vous
remercie merci beaucoup Monsieur
Philippe n'ayez pour le groupe
socialiste mais merci merci président
monsieur le ministre de questions dans
les réponses intéressants les filières
ultramarines d'élevage en particulier
les filières réunionnaises la première
concerne le régime spécifique
d'approvisionnement le plafond non
réhaussé depuis 2013 de 12005 d'euros
pour 199 kg en 2022 l'approvisionnement
était de 273 kg cette évaluation n'ayant
pas été obtenue par les autorités
françaises dans le cadre des
négociations les producteurs locaux
sollicité le gouvernement pour savoir si
l'État sur les fonds nationaux du somme
une enveloppe complémentaire au RSA
serait dégagée pour maintenir le coût de
production d'outre-mer mais ils n'ont
pas eu de réponse à ce jour ma deuxième
question est relative au somme la
première ministre a annoncé lors de sa
récente visite à La Réunion je la cite
toutes les demandes introduites dans le
sium seront acceptées parce qu'il y a eu
ces dernières années parfois des
interstitudes des longues attentes ma
question est très simple elle est de
savoir si cet engagement vaut uniquement
pour cette année ou pour les années
suivantes merci merci beaucoup Monsieur
Eric jardin pour le groupe Renaissance
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre la pyramide des âges du monde
agricole nous enseigne que dans les 10
prochaines années plus d'un agriculteur
sur deux prendra sa retraite on constate
actuellement qu'un tiers des
exploitations ne sont pas transmises
faute de repreneur potentiel dans ce
contexte l'installation de jeunes
agriculteurs y compris Orcades
familiales familial et non issus du
monde du milieu agricole est aujourd'hui
nécessité pour relever le défi du
renouvellement des générations et
assurer la pérennité du modèle
économique conjointement à cet enjeu la
problématique de l'augmentation du prix
du foncier de sa transmission ces 20
dernières années rend complexe
installation des jeunes qui ne peuvent
pas nécessairement faire face au coût du
foncier transmis tandis que dans le
cadre de la reprise d'exploitation il
doivent investir constamment pour
intégrer les transitions climatiques
environnementales technologiques et
numérique parallèlement ils doivent
faire face à une pression fiscale
soutenue qui porte tant sur les
exploitants que les repreneurs monsieur
le ministre quelle articulation
proposerez-vous dans la ploah pour faire
en sorte de faciliter la transmission
des exploitations et du fonciers en même
temps que l'installation des
agriculteurs garantissant ainsi notre
souveraineté
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre vous êtes devenu lundi en
Gironde pour lancer un grand plan
d'arrachage viticole qui se veut dans la
communication sanitaire mais qui est
évidemment un plan pour répondre à très
grave crise que traverse la viticulture
bordelaise je ne vais pas m'étendre sur
ce plan sur des montants qui peuvent
paraître un peu faibles quand même
regardez leurs emprunts que doivent
encore rembourser une partie de ces
viticulteurs on parle d'une crise on
peut aussi considérer qu'il s'agit on
peut à la fois considérer qu'il s'agisse
d'une surproduction et c'est quand même
la philosophie de ce plan d'arrachage
mais on peut aussi considérer d'une
façon un peu plus ambitieuse qui
s'agisse d'un déficit de
commercialisation j'ai deux questions la
première c'est que notre diplomatie
française est très en avant pour pour
faire la promotion et d'exportation des
Airbus ou l'armement quand les la
diplomatie française se mettra au
service de la viticulture pour pouvoir
faire cette même promotion à
l'exportation de nos vins et d'autre
part je relai et je je réponds à la
sollicitation qui a fait de mon collègue
de l'Hérault sur les campagnes honteuses
militaires du ministère de la Santé qui
vise à diaboliser le vin et l'alcool
comptez-vous faire que comptez-vous
faire pour faire cesser cette
diabolisation et faire la promotion
responsable de la consommation du vin
merci Monsieur William Martinez
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre la France a bien du mal à
baisser sa consommation de produits
phytosanitaires pourquoi parce que le
pouvoir que vous représentez se fait le
relais particulièrement zélé des
exigences de l'agro-business et cela
implique de défendre un modèle agricole
archaïque
ultra dépendant à la chimie on se
souvient de cette séquence filmé à la
dérobée dans un salon du Sénat vous avez
dit un lobbyiste tu as vu j'ai bien
défendu les pesticides de l'ironie
paraît-il mais ce qui n'est pas de
l'ironie c'est le coup de pression que
vous avez mis à lances pour contester sa
décision pourtant prise en toute
indépendance et sur la base d'une
expertise scientifique incontestable
d'interdire le S métola chlore un
herbicide cancérigène pour justifier
votre politique pro pesticide pro
herbicide vous opposez la santé et
l'économie sortir de la chimie ce serait
sacrifié des emplois c'est doublement
faux de 1 à la transition vers une
agriculture paysanne permettrait de
créer massivement des emplois de deux
c'est le libre-échange qui représente
une menace pour notre filière agricole
ce que nous attendons d'un ministre de
l'Agriculture c'est qu'il bataille
l'échelle de l'UE et de l'OMC n'ont pas
pour exiger une pose de la
réglementation environnementale mais
pour la renforcer c'est comme ça qu'on
dépendrons notre filière merci beaucoup
monsieur Julien divers merci le
Président Monsieur ministre vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure plusieurs fois
même et game l'essence même des gamines
c'était le partage de la valeur et
d'ailleurs il y a eu plusieurs
dispositifs sur le négociation
commerciale sur laquelle nous sommes
revenus au travers de plusieurs lois et
récemment le Parlement c'est encore
exprimé sur les relations commerciales
et les négociations plus précisément
dernièrement c'est le Ministre de
l'économie ou de lumière qui a annoncé
qu'il fallait revoir les négociations
commerciales au regard d'une inflation
galopante et extrême
revoir les négociations de manière
spontanée sans passer par la loi puisque
pour le coup ce serait hors cadre des
des périodes précisées pour les
négociations commerciales quel est votre
avis là-dessus avant son nom dans ces
discussions l'ouverture ces discussions
ou va-t-il falloir de nouveau légiférer
merci beaucoup chez Madame Géraldine
crangier pour le han merci monsieur le
président alors que bonjour monsieur le
ministre alors que le gouvernement
prépare un nouveau plan de gestion du
loup le monde agricole appelle un plan
de sauvegarde de l'élevage depuis cinq
ans la présence du loup en France a
bondit de 141% aujourd'hui on le
retrouve dans 53 département et l'Office
français de biodiversité a recensé près
de 1000 loups l'année dernière sur notre
territoire soit le double du seuil du
plan loup après deux ans de baisse les
attaques sont repartis à la hausse plus
20% en 2022 est déjà 16% en 2023 face à
cette inquiétante augmentation des
attaques les agriculteurs attendent que
le gouvernement passe à une logique de
régulation du loup le loup qui a
réellement un impact sur le pastoralisme
et la biodiversité coûte aux
collectivités près de 60 millions
d'euros en mesure de protection et
d'indemnisation toutefois ce coût ne
prend pas en compte la détresse des
éleveurs impactés monsieur le ministre
entendez-vous la demande du monde
agricole de régulation du loup merci
merci beaucoup madame relis trouvé pour
les filles
monsieur le ministre je vais vous parler
là en tant que co-rapporteur du groupe
de travail parlementaire sur l'inflation
vous le savez les prix alimentaires ont
augmenté de façon terrible de 15 à 20%
et ça concerne notamment les ménages aux
revenus les plus modestes 16% des gens
disent maintenant qu'ils connaissent la
fin dans ce pays qui est quand même la
sixième puissance du monde
et ça a deux conséquences très concrètes
d'abord l'effondrement de la demande en
bio et de l'offre en bio alors que c'est
sous-emmanuel Macron que les aide au
maintien en bio ont été supprimés donc
que faites-vous en tant que ministre de
l'Agriculture pour contre cet
effondrement du bio et puis deuxième
question sur les marges des grandes
industries agroalimentaires qui flambent
même Bruno Le Maire maintenant le
reconnaît après l'avoir nié mais dans et
toujours aussi impuissant puisqu'il
refuse toujours des réguler les marges
et il refuse d'obliger les industries
agroalimentaires à renégocier donc
êtes-vous aussi vous dans cette
impuissance ou avez-vous prévu quelque
chose pour faire en sorte de réguler et
ses profits merci beaucoup madame Anaïs
Sabatini pour le RN monsieur le ministre
chers collègues de nombreux départements
libéré les orientales subissent
actuellement une sécheresse inédite s'il
a encore trop tôt pour les évaluer
précisément les perceront significatives
voire catastrophiques dans de nombreux
contrats d'assurance une clause définie
que si la paire de récolte n'est pas
uniquement liée à une aléa mais une
décision administrative la perte liée à
ses décisions ne peut pas faire l'objet
d'une indemnisation de l'assureur lors
de votre visite à ma circonscription
vous avez affirmé que même sous la
contrainte d'un arrêté préfectoral de
restriction de l'irrigation l'indemnité
de solidarité nationale s'appliquerait
pleinement pouvez-vous me confirmer cela
par ailleurs quelles sont les mesures
envisagées par le gouvernement pour
soutenir le secteur agricole face aux
épisodes sécheresse qui sont
malheureusement amenés à se répéter à
l'avenir et comment s'assurer que les
assurances jouent pleinement leur rôle
je vous remercie merci beaucoup madame
Mathilde ignié pour LFI
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre l'épisode de grippe aviaire a
été dramatique pour les éleveurs autant
sur le plan financier que psychologique
et à peine la crise est passée de
nouveaux cas sont apparus dans le
Sud-Ouest nous disposons maintenant de
vaccins pour lutter contre cette maladie
mais la vaccination présente de
nombreuses limites en commençant par son
cou particulièrement élevé pour les
petits élevages la vaccination ne doit
donc pas être rendue obligatoire et sont
financement pris en charge en
particulier pour les petits élevages
pouvez-vous nous confirmer que ce sera
bien le cas la nouvelle stratégie
sanitaire prend-elle en compte la
spécificité des élevages plein air et
comme le souligne le rapport
d'information parlementaire présentée en
avril la vaccination ne constitue pas
une solution miracle il faut agir sur la
densité des animaux la segmentation des
filières et la multiplication des flux
qui en découlent donc quelle mesure de
transition comptez-vous proposer aux
filières merci
merci beaucoup Monsieur Lionel Tivoli
pour le RN
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre cela fait 30 ans désormais que
le loup est rappeuri en France et les
Alpes-Maritimes ont été le premier
département à connaître sa apparition en
1992 il provoque depuis des dégâts
considérables sur la faune sauvage sur
nos élevages bovins aux vins et qu'après
régulièrement dans les territoires alpel
les éleveurs lancent l'alerte pour que
l'État agissent à ce titre le lourd est
porté atteinte à plus de 12000 bêtes en
2022 les attaques sur les troupeaux
aurait doublé entre 2012 et 2022
aujourd'hui malgré une présence accrue
des bergers avec leurs troupeau des
dispositifs de protection et de
régulation ainsi que diverses instaurer
le loup devient un danger également pour
l'homme s'il ne s'agit pas bien sûr de
menacer l'espèce il faut hélas la
réguler davantage aujourd'hui les loups
sont aux portes de nos villes et envahi
nos villages de haute montagne attends
quand même un élu à castelier les sauces
village dans le 04 au port de ma
circonscription monsieur le ministre que
comptez-vous faire pour réduire la
présence du loup qui est aujourd'hui sur
l'ensemble de notre territoire
comptez-vous renforcer les quotas de
prélèvement comptez-vous faciliter les
tirs de défense renforcés pour les
éleveurs en cas d'attaque par conséquent
comment comptez-vous protéger nos
éleveurs et protéger aux habitants je
vous en remercie beaucoup Monsieur
pilateau LFI merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre le 10 mars 2023 la
Cour des comptes annonce le mauvais état
des masses d'eau de surface des masses
d'eau souterraines en cause des
pollutions diffuses dans son dernier
rapport sur l'eau publiant en novembre
dernier le Sénat appelait à l'édiction
de normes strictes de rejet et relève
que le meilleur moyen de préserver la
qualité des eaux de surfaces comme des
eaux sous-titres c'est d'abord de ne pas
produire de polluants les plans
ecophytos sont séduire l'usage des
produits phytosanitaires depuis 2008 ont
vu au contraire leur usage augmenté la
Cour des comptes dès 2020 soulignait
cette échec malgré la mobilisation de
fonds publics importants la cour des
comptes appelait déjà l'État à influer
sur les filières et leur mode de
production par l'exercice de ses
compétences normatives et de régulation
invité par le Sénat et la Cour des
comptes le gouvernement n'a pourtant pas
pris ce chemin madame borde l'annonçait
et quand Ecophyto pardon malgré ses
échecs successifs sera encore augmenté
sans régulation d'aucune sorte merci
beaucoup monsieur delapino
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre la question du partage de l'eau
participe aujourd'hui à une forme
d'agrébaching le secteur agroalimentaire
le maraîchage l'arboriculture et la
viticulture constituent les principales
activités économiques de Vaucluse et
aujourd'hui des jeunes hésitent à
reprendre des exploitations si le
recours à l'irrigation n'est plus
garantie dans ces secteurs aussi
pouvez-vous garantir une priorité
d'usage pour la culture de l'eau afin de
préserver notre autonomie alimentaire
pour l'avenir
merci beaucoup alors y a-t-il d'autres
questions que j'ai manqué on est déjà un
record là on a 30 questions c'est bon
pour tout le monde pas de frustration et
bien monsieur le ministre vous avez 19
vous avez 19 questions pardon vous avez
19 minutes pour répondre à
ces 30 questions et donc ça vous
permettra d'être alors à votre prochain
rendez-vous important je crois donc
monsieur le ministre c'est à vous
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs alors je vais essayer de
regrouper mais
on va voir si j'ai le sens de la
synthèse
vous remercier de l'intérêt que vous
portez à la Cour des comptes
il faut faire attention j'ai échangé je
vais vous le dire avec Pierre Moscovici
je le verrai en fin de semaine je pense
qu'on a toujours besoin y compris quand
on n'est pas d'accord de se dire des
choses et je répète j'invite au delà des
recommandations à regarder ce que dit la
Cour des comptes elle dit des choses
intéressantes sur la question de se
mettre en adéquation l'offre et la
demande elle dit des choses
intéressantes sur l'intérêt des élevages
mixtes des choses intéressantes sur
l'intérêt de la Cour des comptes oui
monsieur Vigier je vous assure il faut
le lire elle dit des choses
intéressantes
on est d'accord là dessus vous le savez
d'ailleurs elle dit des choses
intéressantes sur ce que apporte
l'agriculture dans le cycle azoté et
dans le cycle de décarbonation que vous
voulez engager évidemment
oui mais on peut ne pas être d'accord
c'est pas ma bible ça a l'air d'être la
vôtre mais je
votre livre de chevet du moment mais
ça pose ça pose il faut que si je
commence à moi-même faire des
digressions dans l'éducation mais ça va
pas arriver ça pose simplement la
question et là je suis d'accord avec les
expressions qui a eu on peut pas engager
une transition en disant le seul
perspective que je vous donne c'est la
disparition parce que c'est pas la
perspective de l'élevage français j'ai
besoin d'élevage en France pour assurer
ma souveraineté alimentaire pour faire
mon cycle du carbone pour maintenir mes
prairies pour maintenir le réseau de
haie pour lutter contre les incendies
donc j'ai besoin de l'élevage et on pose
ce postulat ça serait bien qu'on le pose
dans la société vis-à-vis de nos
éleveurs parce que ça permettrait d'une
certaine façon qu'on puisse répondre à
leurs inquiétudes et qu'on passe pas
notre vie à dire il faut rendre le
métier plus attractif comment vous les
avez être attractifs quand vous avez des
gens qui ont permanence viennent vous
expliquer vous faites un métier qui
n'est pas un métier
utile au-delà de son côté alimentaire et
donc c'est là dessus qu'on a besoin de
travailler et je crois que nous
partageons ce point de vue mais on a
besoin de faire évoluer aussi sur les
questions d'élevage on voit bien qu'il y
a des situations qui sont importantes ça
me permet de dire un mot sur la question
oui on a une baisse du cheptel qui est
lié à ce cet élevage bashing parfois
on a aussi une baisse du cheptel en
particulier sur le lait qui est lié à la
question de la rémunération on a une
question une baisse du cheptel Kelly
aussi sur le lait elle une augmentation
de la productivité il faut le dire aussi
la productivité d'une vache laitière
aujourd'hui n'est pas tout à fait là
pour donc a besoin équivalent il y a un
peu moins de vache pour produire autant
de lait c'est pas complètement mais ce
n'est pas ça le fait principal mais
c'est tous ces facteurs qui se combinent
et qui peuvent expliquer les choses il
me semble que c'est important important
de le dire et voilà ce que je voulais
dire sur les questions d'élevage le
président Chassaigne
lui faire deux remarques sur le PSN le
premier c'est 80 tous les agriculteurs
ne rentrent pas dans les écuries c'est
80% la cible plutôt qui rentre dans ces
dans ces dispositifs donc tous ne
rentrent pas nous avons fait le choix
que je crois juste de dire il vaut mieux
qu'on fasse rentrer tout le monde et
qu'on monte tout le monde plutôt que
dire il y a deux agricultures qui se
créent ceux qui ne serait pas sensible à
caisse ces questions environnementales
ou ceux qu'on a n'inviterait pas y être
plus engagé et ceux qui le seraient on
n'a pas besoin de d'avoir ça on a besoin
que tout le monde s'engage et c'est bien
l'objectif de il m'invite à faire des
modifications dans le PSN il le sait
d'ailleurs président chassen le sait
on peut pas faire des modifications
substantielles chaque année
on peut faire des ajustements en cours
de route et à un bilan ami parcours je
rappelle que nous avons commencé la mise
en oeuvre de la PAC 2023 c'est la
première année
bon donc si on pouvait un peu donner de
la stabilité quand les règles il faut
déjà que les agriculteurs s'approprient
les règles
une fois qu'ils vont s'être approprié
les règles mais on peut toujours dire il
y a qu'un faucon mais pas de problème
mais je vous dis qu'on a pas le droit de
modifier substantiellement le PSN et
donc on ne modifiera pas
substantiellement le PSN voilà parce que
je peux pas dire à des agriculteurs qui
ont commencé à s'engager dans la
rotation des cultures en fait je vous ai
pas dit ça va encore changer et donc on
a besoin de réfléchir sur la future Pax
qu'on peut faire on a besoin de
réfléchir dans les modifications à mes
cartes parcours ce qu'on peut faire on a
besoin de réfléchir des ajustements
qu'on peut faire mais n'essayons de ne
pas changer les règles tout le temps
parce que qu'est-ce qu'elle est l'acteur
qui peut accepter que tous les matins on
lui change ses règles
aucun pas plus en agriculture que dans
le reste je connais pas une personne
vous-même madame pochon d'ailleurs sans
doute qui accepterait qu'on lui dise du
jour au lendemain je te change ta règle
et encore je te la rechange le lendemain
alors
deuxième élément deuxième élément j'ai
bien noté la question de Monsieur
travers sur ces nutri-score alors comme
on est sur un dispositif qui n'est pas
européen à ma dispositif à plusieurs
pays il y a eu un vote aux deux tiers
qui nous a pas été favorable je pense
qu'on a besoin de reposer comme cette
question là parce que l'algorithme
produit parfois des choses
algorithmiques toujours intéressantes
qui nous passionne vous et moi monsieur
travers mais il faut qu'on se pose quand
même la question du classement parce que
là il y a quelque chose qui est un peu
mieux j'ajoute que je trouve qu'on
aurait intérêt me semble-t-il à avoir et
j'essaie de prêcher alors les collègues
italien n'est pas tout à fait pro
avancer sur le sujet mais je trouve que
sur la question de l'étiquetage on
aurait intérêt à avoir des étiquetages
communs parce qu'avoir cette pays d'un
côté trois ou quatre de l'autre et
d'autres qui ne font rien sa nuit à la
lisibilité pour le consommateur et je
trouve que c'est un peu dommage et par
ailleurs ça ne peut pas être obligatoire
puisque nous n'avons pas un étiquetage
quand même il me semble que c'est un
élément
important monsieur Alexandre vous m'avez
alerté sur enfin alerté sur à la fois
notamment l'élevage et la question
Mercosur d'abord je rappelle que le
Mercosur n'est un accord qui n'existe
pas
donc ne parlez pas de tout ça c'est la
photo Mercosur parce que le Mercosur
abandon mais le Mercosur n'existe pas et
la position française là-dessus et
Claire le président de la République
arrive en disant que nous ne sommes pas
au rendez-vous de ce que nous attendons
sur Mercure ça pose la question des
mesures miroir nous avons cette question
vous poser sur les questions des mesures
miroir par exemple sur les antibiotiques
c'est ce que nous faisons et donc ne
croyez pas que nous restions les bras
ballants quand il y a besoin de faire
des mesures miroir nous le faisons
évidemment c'est un élément très
important il m'a il m'a interrogé je le
dis au passage sur la question de
l'influence de navire ça me permettra
aussi de répondre à Monsieur bolo il y a
plusieurs autres intervenants d'abord
sur la nature des élevages qui seront
concernés je ne sais plus c'est
peut-être vous monsieur qui m'a appelé
pour savoir les petits et les grands
élevages sur la vaccination
tous les élevages sont concernés par la
vaccination c'est vous madame pardon
est-ce elle sera elle sera obligatoire
parce que on a une politique de
vaccination pour essayer de diminuer la
pression gripaviaire il faut que tout le
monde soit dans cette logique là parce
que c'est un sujet d'intérêt général et
d'intérêt public cette affaire là
deuxième élément on est en train de
regarder quels sont les conditionnements
qui permettront que les petits élevages
puissent en prendre compte troisième
élément
je sais plus qui disait sur la question
de l'engagement et Philippe boulot
l'aurait parlé à juste titre l'État a
été au rendez-vous sur une filière qui
fait 6 milliards de chiffre d'affaires
on a mis un milliard d'euros
d'indemnisation de nature diverses et
c'était bien normal donc on peut pas
dire qu'on n'est pas été au rendez-vous
de l'attente des éleveurs on est en
train de déployer le plan l'idée de la
vaccination c'est une charge qui est qui
est très lourde j'aurais vraiment salué
d'ailleurs la mobilisation des services
de l'État en déconcentré et au National
vous n'imaginez pas ce que c'est que de
traiter l'influence de navire au
quotidien
et la charge que ça met sur les agents
du ministère au niveau national comme au
niveau territorial il faut leur rendre
hommage et de le travail qu'on est en
train de faire par ailleurs pour
déployer l'implant maximal ça me donne
l'occasion de dire je sais les
impatiences
j'avais dit automne automne c'est pour
moi c'est premier le polyton c'est le
jour de l'automne je suis un peu
calendaire pardon de le dire comme ça
pour moi c'est autour du 1er octobre que
ça se fait et donc c'est bien l'objectif
que nous avons si on pouvait faire plus
court vous pensez bien qu'on le ferait
et si il y avait un miracle on le ferait
mais déployer un plan vaccinal c'est de
la logistique déployer un plan vaccinal
c'est des vétérinaires déployer un plan
vaccinal c'est de la traçabilité je sais
que ça paraît un peu long mais on
devrait plutôt tous se féliciter que
nous arrivions en fait au bout du chemin
que nous étions tracés dans le
calendrier à date où je vous parle que
nous étions tracés dernier élément le
financement moi j'ai fait les passer les
précommandes on est en cours de
discussion avec les les filières pour
regarder que l'État fasse la part au
début mais que les filières la première
charge ensuite ça ne permet pas
complètement illogique parce que l'État
peut être en permanence en soutien
l'important c'est qu'on sort de la
grippe aviaire et donc on est en train
de regarder avec les filières en bonne
intelligence la façon dont les choses
peuvent être financées il me semble que
c'est un élément très important je me
suis bolo je lui répond sur la question
des accouverts toutes les indemnisations
n'ont pas été produites parce que c'est
en deuxième intention ou troisième
intention donc dans le processus il
n'était pas illogique qu'il soit plutôt
à la fin du processus en revanche je
vais m'assurer que ce qui va chez les
uns doit bien retourner chez les autres
et qu'il y aurait pas quelque chose il
disait faut pas que ce boulot dit faut
pas que vous vous intervie bah si c'est
quand même de l'argent public qui a une
destination donc je m'interdis pas quand
même de regarder ouvert l'argent public
qui a une destination qui est celle de
préserver les filières à mon aval mais
aussi les filaments parce que sinon je
ferai des faux à la chose
Monsieur Roland et quelques autres
ont évoqué la question la question du
loup
la question de la prédation il me semble
que c'est un puis la question de la
Bruxelloise mais je vais essayer d'être
sur la question du loup on a un sujet
alors un pochon vous dites il faut qu'on
débatte il faut pas qu'on débatte il
faut qu'on comprenne des décisions hein
faut qu'on arrête de débattre faut qu'on
se pose des questions non mais il faut
qu'on se pose des questions et j'espère
vous retrouver avec la j'espère vous
retrouver madame pochon j'essaie de vous
répondre si vous voulez qu'on se parle à
travers le micro mais si on pouvait
trouver la autre chose que Yaka faucon
et il faut qu'on dialogue on est dans
des territoires où la pression du loup
rend maintenant impossible ou quasi
impossible ou quasi invivable alors vous
pouvez pas vous émouvoir de la situation
de l'éleveur et pas dire qu'est-ce qu'on
fait et le qu'est-ce qu'on fait c'est
pas en dialogue c'est alors laissez-moi
finir laissez-moi laissez-moi finir
laissez-moi finir ah mais c'est le loup
c'est quand même un truc passionnel je
suis opérationnel monsieur le ministre
on laisse le ministre on a un statut du
look et le statut convention de Berne
Directive Habitat guide interprétatif
attendait
pas trop vite sur moi
n'attaquez pas tout de suite le ministre
à la gorge on a un statut du loup qui
est le statut qu'on connaît on a un
statut du look où le casting 2 on a
besoin avec les scientifiques de dire on
avait dit 500 c'est que le seuil à
atteindre pour protéger en nombre
d'autres disent maintenant il faut
regarder mélanger génétique bon très
bien mais on a besoin un moment de se
dire à quel moment on assume que la
viabilité est assumée non seulement à
l'échelle française mais à l'échelle du
massif alpin parce que je pense qu'on a
c'est une population qui navigue sur le
massif alpin donc on peut partager le
nombre si je peux dire avec d'autres
collègues et donc moi je vais on va
interroger les scientifiques on va
interroger la commission parce que c'est
une affaire d'abord de la commission
pour demander à quel moment on dit il
faut qu'on donne une perspective de
protection de l'espèce et une
perspective de dire les armontent au
ciel ou pas parce que sinon on va pas y
arriver dans le dialogue on a avec les
agriculteurs il me semble que c'est on
vous êtes pour ceux qui m'ont interrogé
vous vous n'êtes pas sans avoir été sur
un lieu de prédation quand on voit les
l'état de détresse d'un agriculteurs on
peut pas en permanence dire bon monsieur
c'est comme ça
on peut pas dire aux éleveurs faut
produire on est on n'est pas souverain
en entre autres en élevage de moutons et
on dit bah oui mais le pastoralisme va
disparaître parce que c'est comme ça non
c'est je me résous pas ça c'est pas mon
périmètre premier mais moi je pense que
c'est une question centrale dans les
zones d'élevage en montagne en
particulier en attendant que ça arrive
ça a été dit par un de vous un des
députés du rassemblement national je
pense qu'il est je crois qu'il est ce
département dans d'autres territoires je
pense à la Franche-Comté je pense à la
Bourgogne ou c'est en train de
progresser donc il faut qu'on se mette
d'accord sur un statut et pas être
rigide sur sa bouche pas on touche à
rien et les armandes au ciel donc on a
besoin de se poser cette question là et
puis deux on a besoin dans l'intervalle
d'avoir des des réflexions sur des
mesures de simplification
simplification sur les indemnisations
prise en charge d'indemnisation plus
large
si vous m'interpellez au milieu je vais
présenter de la plus la plus grande
Baptiste vous avez raison parce que
vous-même vous êtes assez concerné dans
votre département j'en sais quelque
chose on a besoin effectivement de
regarder comment on peut mieux prendre
en charge on a besoin de regarder
comment on raccourcit les délais on a
besoin donc on est en train de
travailler je voyais ce matin ma
collègue Bérengère Couillard pour avoir
des dispositions immédiates et que par
ailleurs dans le plan lourd on pose des
questions que je viens de poser on a
besoin de se dire qu'il y a des endroits
où la protégeabilité des troupeaux n'est
pas possible
protégehabilité ou pas protéger donc il
faut qu'on le pose tranquillement sans
dire c'est comme ça ça change rien parce
que sinon on met les gens dans une
situation désespérance pour avoir été
sans doute le ministre de l'Agriculture
qui a été le plus sur des lieux de
prédation donc je vois à peu près de
quoi il ressemble comme mes autres
prédécesseurs Stéphane traverella ça a
monté aussi de on a mais on est tous
collectivement à devoir porter cette
responsabilité devant l'opinion et de ne
pas se défausser des débats que je mets
sur la table parce que ça peut pas être
simplement débrouillez-vous parce que
sinon et on aura en conscience des
choses à dire aux citoyens sur ces
questions là de prédation
comment
non non
attendez
pas d'interpellation directe je crois
que chacun a pu poser ses 30 questions
donc merci parce que c'est un animal
non non non non c'est pas des méthodes
poursuivez s'il vous plaît
interpeller le ministre maintenant
je vous remercie de m'avoir alerté sur
une défaillance j'allais taquin je suis
content que la PAC 2023 démarre mieux
que la pack 2015
ou le système informatique avait buggé
et où pendant un an et demi les
agriculteurs ils ont pas pu déclarer
donc c'est pas faux en tout cas
et donc le système est quand cette
défaillance a été signalée elle est elle
est corrigée elle est réparée donc ça
marche ça marche c'est compliqué parce
que une nouvelle Pâque c'est un nouveau
logiciel c'est très con c'est complexe
et vous le savez comment mais ça ça a
été réparé il me semble que c'est un
élément important je ne vois pas d'où
sort l'idée ou le sur la question de
l'inflation ça voudrait dire que 5
milliards que la moitié de la PAC aurait
été absorbée par l'inflation
on arrête de s'interpeller monsieur le
ministre vous répondez et s'il y a
d'autres questions
d'intégrer le service de remplacement
des bergers parce que je pense que c'est
un élément important sur ces questions
monsieur Lopez linori vous m'avez
interrogé en disant les viticulteurs
sont délaissés pardon
gel en 2021 un milliard
crise dans le Bordelais
en 2021 donc donc ne venez pas nous dire
à nous qu'on n'a pas fait ce qu'il
fallait sur la filière viticole bon donc
deuxième élément il me semble que
là-dessus on a besoin de travailler on a
besoin de travailler j'ai entendu les
messages que vous avez sur oui on a on
n'a pas besoin d'être sur une stratégie
de dénigrement de ces produits qui sont
des produits emblématiques ça n'empêche
pas qu'on doit pas en rabattre sur les
questions de santé publique mais je suis
d'accord avec vous il faut qu'on fasse
attention dans les messages et vous
m'avez pas trouvé sur un autre chemin
j'ajoute que le sujet français de la
viticulture c'est quand même le sujet de
l'export parce que c'est plutôt l'export
qui doit nous intéresser parce que
l'essentiel y compris sur le Bordelais
monsieur de Fournas je sais que vous
n'êtes pas très pour les échanges
internationaux mais heureusement qu'il y
a des échanges internationaux pour le
bordeaux hein et le bordeaux aujourd'hui
souffre c'est pas la consommation
intérieure qui va soutenir c'est pas la
consommation intérieure seulement qui va
soutenir le maintien du Bordelais il
faut se dire des choses comme elles sont
c'est des éléments importants donc
on essaye de
on essaye on essaye de travailler pour
soutenir quand il y a des crises on a
besoin je crois que c'est Monsieur de
fonda c'est la raison d'avoir une
diplomatie agricole qui fasse la
valorisation et c'est ce que je fais
tous les moments où je peux me déplacer
face à valorisation nos produits parce
que la France elle a une vocation
d'exportatrice et il faut qu'on la
maintienne évidemment
monsieur Giovanni William a parlé des
questions de molécules interdites oui et
il y a une partie des molécules
interdites après ça doit faire l'objet
de mesures miroir pour faire en sorte
que justement à l'extérieur de nos
frontières il y a pas des des produits
qui viennent sans qu'on en ait voulu
madame Petel vous m'avez évoqué la
question de l'eau
j'invite à nous interroger
collectivement je crois que je vous le
disais sur
je suis pas sûr qu'aujourd'hui on
pourrait faire Serre-Ponçon et pourtant
tout le monde peut se féliciter
aujourd'hui d'avoir fait ses
Serre-Ponçon c'est juste qu'elle doit
nous appeler un peu de vigilance sur des
postures dogmatiques qui viseraient à
dire que on peut pas faire heureusement
qu'il y a des gens qui a 60 ans
pensaient qu'il fallait faire
circonscient parce que ça marche ça et
ça a permis de résoudre un problème
fondamental et ça permet de résoudre
aussi une question de comment j'ai en
collectif de l'eau par ailleurs je suis
assez d'accord avec vous je pense qu'on
doit pouvoir développer avec la
grivevoltase d'autres fonctions que
celle de production d'énergie parce que
ça peut être un outil au service de la
production le système d'ombrelle peut
permettre de protéger de la canicule le
système d'ombrelle peut protéger parfois
d'autres sujets par exemple je pense à
la grêle et donc la grille voltaïque
peut aussi au service de cette
philosophie là il me semble que c'est un
élément important monsieur Nury j'ai
bien noté ce que vous m'avez demandé sur
la question de la tuberculose d'abord
qu'on essaie alors d'abord on a besoin
de traiter des questions de faune
sauvage parce que vous avez raison ici
le blaireau là le sanglier il me semble
que les chasseurs ont une part de
responsabilité qui doivent porter avec
nous pour faire en sorte que là où on
doit faire porter la pression on puisse
le faire parce que sinon on va se
retrouver avec une augmentation qui est
un peu inquiétante deuxièmement en
expérimente un certain nombre de sujets
j'ajoute qu'on est en train en cours
d'expérimentation d'une décidément c'est
la période des vaccins d'expérimentation
de vaccin du blaireau parce que c'est
l'un des principaux vecteurs avec le
sanglier pour regarder ce que ça fait
enfin pour la question de
l'intervention des collectivités locales
oui les régions et départements peuvent
intervenir dans la limite du plafond
dette parce qu'il y a un limite de
plafond dette qui est quand même de 65 à
80 % selon la nature des investissements
ce qui est quand même me semble-t-il un
peu significatif mais comme c'est pas
lieu de le traité je vous propose
éventuellement qu'avec mes équipes vous
puissiez regarder s'il y a des choses
qu'on doit pouvoir améliorer il me
semble que c'est un élément évidemment
très important
sur la question de l'étiquetage
monsieur Martine vous allez dire est-ce
qu'on pourrait pas être
l'étiquetage parfois il nous ennuie mais
souvent il nous protège
on peut pas et donc je comprends la
logique et la vôtre mais je suis très
content que par exemple sur l'étiquetage
de volaille la position française les
emporté parce que ça permet qu'on ne
puisse pas dire c'est du plein air quand
c'est pas du plein air et c'est une
bataille que je suis content qu'on ait
pu faire aboutir les collègues également
n'étaient pas sur cette logique là
ça nous protège quand même qu'on fasse
venir de la voyance que c'est pas du
plein air et donc je sais que ça peut
être une contrainte mais il y a eu
d'ailleurs je parle sur le contrôle de
ceux qui ont travaillé avec nous sur
egalim dans les précédents épisodes il y
avait parfois des on a parfois fait du
Grand déclaratif et du législatif on a
mis du l'étiquetage et on savait en
votant ça que de toute façon ça passera
pas la rampe européenne donc c'est pas
la voix me semble-t-il il me semble que
la voix en revanche en intra-européen
c'est qu'on fasse en sorte qu'on est les
mêmes règles on intra-européen c'est la
seule voie c'est la seule voie parce que
sinon évidemment on y arrivera pas sur
le sur cette question là me semble-t-il
c'est important j'ai répondu sur la
question du loup à Madame pochon vous
l'aviez mis pardon elle est plus là mais
vous l'aviez mis dans le paquet Mondi
alisation c'était pas un paquet global
enfin je veux dire la mondialisation est
comptable de tout
sauf de la présence du Lot quoi enfin
peut-être être d'accord là-dessus au
moins semble-t-il Monsieur Roland j'ai
pas répondu sur la question de la
Bruxelloise pardon comme je comme
on a essayé de faire ce qu'il fallait
sous la contrainte aussi de décision de
décision qui n'ont qui ont fait l'objet
de recours devant le Tribunal je pense
qu'on a fait ce qu'on avait à faire dans
le cadre de droit qui nous est qui était
notre on a besoin de regarder sur les
questions des indemnisations on la
revalorisé d'ailleurs une partie des
indemnisations on a besoin de regarder
avec eux et on a besoin d'essayer
d'éradiquer parce que je pense que la
voix sur la bruxello c'est l'éradication
et c'est possible sans l'outils et donc
on a besoin de retravailler avec les
élèves ce que je sais alors on essaie
d'assouplir un certain nombre de mesures
on essaie d'accélérer les tests pour pas
retrouver avec des élevages qui restent
très longtemps en suspens si je peux
dire sans pouvoir commercialisé et ça
c'est des éléments mais en tout cas
merci de m'avoir sollicité je sais que
vous êtes mobilisé plusieurs de vos
collègues parce que c'est un c'est des
filières d'excellence ça signifie qu'ils
sont en grande difficulté d'où l'intérêt
de faire de la prophylaxie quoi
on a besoin de faire ça partout me
semble-t-il
je finis j'ai été trop long sur la
question là j'ai mal écrit les questions
donc du coup le loup je l'ai fait l'eau
monsieur pinato
là c'était la Cour des comptes autre
version autre rapport au 2 salles de
l'ambiance
oui
la Cour des comptes oui pardon
la Cour des comptes
ça y est je me suis fait troubler parce
que vous avez raison j'ai pas répondu à
votre question
la Cour des comptes a dit un certain
nombre de choses nous on essaie de
trouver une trajectoire moi la
responsabilité qu'elle a l'autre c'est
trouver une trajectoire de réduction des
produits phytos ça fera l'objet me
semble-t-il la discussion que nous
aurons avec vous la commission d'enquête
ça n'est est une chose de dire il faut
faire est une autre d'essayer de trouver
des alternatives moi vous ne trouverez
toujours sur le chemin de dire qu'il
faut trouver une trajectoire de
réduction simplement il faut que
j'arrive à trouver des alternatives
parce que sinon c'est ça si on arrive
pas à trouver des alternatives on met
les gens en situation d'un pince il me
semble que c'est un élément important
monsieur delepino m'a parlé du partage
de l'eau oui ça fait c'est vous hein on
avait parlé
c'est une des sujets qu'on va essayer de
poser dans la loi d'orientation c'est
dans la souveraineté comment on dit
l'eau alors je sais pas si c'est au
dessus de quoi c'est en dessous de ce
coincé c'est un bon sujet non non mais
l'eau agricole c'est pas la même eau
agricole quand il s'agit d'abreuver un
troupeau que quand il s'agirait de faire
autre chose donc il faudrait faire aussi
des hiérarchies à l'intérieur donc c'est
un débat qui n'est pas binaire vous
voyez ce que je veux dire notre affaire
d'ailleurs vous l'avez pas poser comme
ça mais on a besoin quand même de faire
un peu d'hirardisation parce que c'est
mais on a besoin d'eau en agriculture et
donc il faut que ça fasse partie des
usages et c'est ce qu'on fait quand vous
regardez ce qui se passe au niveau des
arrêtés préfectoraux c'est ce qu'on a
fait dans les Pyrénées-Orientales ça me
permet de répondre sur les
Pyrénées-Orientales d'ailleurs oui ça
sera bien Madame la Députée ça sera bien
dans le cas de ce que j'ai dit
c'est-à-dire c'est une dérogation qu'on
fait sur les Pyrénées-Orientales pour
les collections soient très clair devant
vous parce que là on est dans une
situation dramatique on a besoin j'en ai
parlé avec les assurances l'autre jour
d'avoir une trajectoire une réflexion
une trajectoire sur d'autres épisodes
qui risquent d'arriver dans d'autres
dans d'autres secteurs parce que sinon
on va déstabiliser complètement notre
notre
régime assurantiel et par ailleurs
pardon sans avoir des réponses toutes
faites et c'est pas facile je le
reconnais que c'est pas facile il faut
qu'on regarde dans ces dans ces
territoires qui vont être soumis à
l'hyper contrainte du dérèglement
climatique qu'est-ce qu'on peut proposer
comme modèle avec un peu d'accès à l'eau
mais beaucoup de résilience
j'étais assis tout avant enfin après
avoir été dans votre département quand
vous avez 90 mm d'eau en 13 mois vous
avez un problème
alors certains me disent changer de
modèle bah il y a plus de modèles
alternatif parce que une vigne comme
résilience il me semble que c'est un
élément très très pour le coup c'est
très résilient donc on a besoin de
pouvoir trouver des modèles il faut
qu'on y travaille avec des acteurs et je
reconnais que dans des territoires comme
cela en particulier ça va être plus
difficile que d'autres mais on a besoin
ça rejoint la question de l'épineau de
travailler sur la question
de l'eau
alors après monsieur vous me posiez une
question sur le sur les questions
ultramarines
sur la question j'ai vu les questions
que vous m'avez posé on va travailler
c'est Monsieur maillet
vous m'avez posé deux séries de
questions on va réunir le surnomme pour
regarder ça et pour essayer de répondre
à ces éléments là que vous posez sur la
table
je vous ai pas oublié mais parce que je
voyais monsieur qui disait vous m'avez
pas donc j'ai bien vu votre question sur
la question de tramarine on a besoin de
retravailler ça a été dit d'ailleurs par
un de vos collègues tout à l'heure sur
aussi des territoires qui ne peuvent pas
utiliser des produits phyto et par
ailleurs les et là c'est les mesures
miroirs qui doivent répondre parce que
c'est vrai c'est assez curieux quand
même qu'on autorise en Europe des
produits qu'on interdit en France et qui
ne peut pas faire dans les territoires
ultramarins là on a un problème de
distorsion que sur lequel il faut
travailler on a besoin de travailler
aussi il me semble-t-il puisque le plan
de souveraineté frus et légumes c'est
plutôt un point d'autonomie alimentaire
dans ces territoires là et on a besoin
de travailler avec vous sur la façon
d'atteindre cette autonomie alimentaire
on a vu à quel point la crise covid a
posé des problèmes
d'alimentation et à quel point
l'inflation est encore plus prégnante
dans ces territoires là plutôt que dans
d'autres me semble-t-il
[Musique]
si j'ai oublié
sécheresse dans le 64 et on fait passer
un mot en disant on a oublié la
sécheresse alors d'abord regardons le
vert à moitié plein
les Pyrénées-Atlantiques de 64 donc
département bien connu
n'avait jamais été depuis très longtemps
que classé dans le régime du calamité
agricole on a baissé les seuils d'accès
pour tous les départements français
parce qu'on assemble après il y a des
critères il y a des seuils alors ce que
je vous propose c'est ce qu'on a
commencé à faire parce que d'autres
parlementaires de ce département le
président du Département moi là était
sur les questions j'ai demandé à rien
l'examen des dossiers mais un examen
avec la logique je peux pas déroger aux
règles qui s'applique dans 65 dans le 40
et dans le 33 en numéro de département
et dire dans le 64 on fait différemment
on comprenait que c'est non mais
il reste de l'argent si je dis j'ouvre
les critères je les ouvre pour tout le
monde parce que je pense que vous êtes
comment attacher au principe d'égalité
donc il restera plus d'argent à la fin
et après j'irai voir en disant il m'en
faut 100 ou c'est parce que ça va vite
ce genre d'exercice il y a des règles
qui étaient connus j'essaie de regarder
avec bienveillance les dossiers et
réexaminés quand il y a des choses qui
sont incompréhensibles pour les
agriculteurs je comprends votre demande
on a déjà fait une première un premier
balayage honnêtement il y a des dossiers
qui effectivement avait échappé pour des
raisons c'est pas si c'est l'algorithme
qui nous est cher avec Stéphane travers
mais en tout cas il y avait quelque
chose qui n'avait pas bien marché mais
donc on est bien attentif à ça monsieur
enfin je ne peux pas ne pas me priver de
dire à Monsieur martinet
on gagne jamais à détourner la vérité
je sais que vous êtes
vous êtes prêt à faire ça je répondais à
une journaliste que vous pourrez faire
témoigner à votre procès stalinien à une
badinerie à laquelle donc ça n'était pas
un lobbyiste c'était une journaliste et
un journaliste qui m'avait avec lequel
je présentais alors si vous pouviez
juste je vous demande juste une chose
Monsieur Martinez juste une chose c'est
de temps en temps de dire la vérité on
gagne vachement dans le débat public
merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
merci pour votre temps
semaine prochaine les réunions lundi on
a une CMP qui est prévu que les
sénateurs sur le plafonnement de
l'indice des loyers mardi à 18h45 on
aura l'audition en vertu de l'article 13
de la constitution de Madame Laurence
boribansel que le Président de la
République envisage de renouveler en
tant que président du directeur de la
Compagnie nationale du Rhône à 21h30 on
aura éventuellement nouvelle lecture la
proposition de loi maintenant
provisionnement le plafonnement de
l'indice locatif et le mercredi 14 en
alzanne donc on a une grosse grosse
semaine en comme écho la semaine
prochaine merci encore monsieur le
ministre merci chers collègues et puis
bonne soirée